This episode is supported by Anthropic, the team behind Claude. Now, history's biggest leaps started as hard questions that people didn't want asked. Yeah, there's a classic example of that at the end of the 15th century. And the hard question in particular was, what is out there beyond the Atlantic Ocean to the west? And as you will know, the man who found the answer to that question was the explorer Christopher Columbus. And he realizes, or rather everybody else realizes, that there is a vast continent out there. And it is, of course, the Americas. So Anthropic knows the importance of questions. And it's why Anthropic is founded on one hard question above all. How can we ensure that the AI revolution
本期节目由Claude背后的团队Anthropic赞助。历史上的重大飞跃往往始于人们不愿触及的难题。在15世纪末，就有一个经典的例子。当时一个特别棘手的难题是：大西洋以西究竟有什么？众所周知，找到这个答案的人是探险家克里斯托弗·哥伦布。他意识到，或者说其他人意识到，那里有一片广阔的大陆。当然，那就是美洲。Anthropic深知提问的重要性，这也是Anthropic创立时最核心的一个难题：我们如何确保人工智能革命
really goes well for ordinary people? So they asked over 100,000 people. And what came back wasn't just fear. There was hope as well. People wanted to know, will cancer ever be cured? It turns out that there is hope in hard questions. Ask yours at clodd.aI slash rest is history. And keep thinking. We're some see heroes, and others see egos. Bloomberg sees the era of billionaire athletes. While others follow the noise, we follow the money. Learn more at Bloomberg.com.
能真正造福普通人？为此，他们询问了超过10万人。得到的反馈不仅有恐惧，还有希望。人们想知道，癌症终有一天会被治愈吗？事实证明，难题中蕴含着希望。请访问clodd.ai/restishistory提出你的问题，并保持思考。有些人看到的是英雄，有些人看到的是自负。彭博社看到的是亿万富翁运动员的时代。当别人追逐喧嚣时，我们追逐金钱。更多信息请访问Bloomberg.com。
At Suez, one of our Navy sloops will take you down the Red Sea. They'll have you at Zola. That's the port for Abyssinia. by the middle of February and it can't take above a week to get the silver up country to this place called Atagrat. That's where General Napier
在苏伊士，我们的一艘海军单桅帆船会带你沿红海南下。他们会在二月中旬把你送到阿比西尼亚的港口祖拉。把白银运到那个叫阿塔格拉特的地方，花不了一周时间。那是纳皮尔将军
will be. Napier? Not Bob the Bug Hunter. What the blazes is he doing in Abyssinia? We haven't got a station there. Oh, we have by now, you may be sure. He was laughing in disbelief. You mean to tell me you haven't heard?
驻扎的地方。纳皮尔？不是那个“臭虫猎人”鲍勃吧？他到底在阿比西尼亚干什么？我们那里又没有驻军。哦，你放心，现在肯定有了。他难以置信地笑着说。你是说你还没听说吗？
Why, he's invaded the place. with an army from Inger! The silver is to help fund his campaign, don't you see? Good God, Flashy! Where have you been? Hold up, held up, can't you? Why is he invading? To rescue the captives. Our consul, envoys, missionaries.
他带着一支从印度来的军队入侵了那里！白银是用来资助他的军事行动的，你明白吗？天哪，弗莱什！你到底去哪儿了？等等，别急，行吗？他为什么要入侵？为了营救人质。我们的领事、特使、传教士。
They're held prisoner by this mad cannibal king, and he's chaining him and flogging him and kicking up no end of a row. Teodros, his name is. And you mean to say, you've not heard of him? I'll be damned. Why, there's been our brawl in Parliament? Our greatest queen writing letters? A penny or more on the income tax? It's true. So that is from a memoir by one of Victorian Britain's most decorated officers, General Sir Harry Flashman V.C. Recalling his part in what he in his memoir calls the strangest campers. in the history of British arms. And this is the subject of today's episode and our next
他们被那个疯狂的食人国王囚禁了，他把他们锁起来、鞭打他们，闹得不可开交。他叫提奥多罗斯。你是说你没听说过他？我真不敢相信。议会里不是吵翻天了吗？我们伟大的女王不是写信了吗？所得税不是涨了一便士甚至更多吗？是真的。所以，这段话出自维多利亚时代英国最受勋的军官之一，哈里·弗莱什曼爵士（维多利亚十字勋章获得者）的回忆录。他回忆起自己在回忆录中所称的“英国军队史上最奇怪的战役”中的经历。这就是今天和下一期节目的主题
episode, the Abyssinian Expedition of 1868. And I think it's fair to say that this isn't an expedition that is particularly well known, not one of the kind of the classic Victorian expeditions, but it is a banger. And if you go to pretty much any of Britain's leading museums, so the British Museum, the British Library, the VNA, the Bodleon, you will find manuscripts or relics or jewels or treasures that were brought back to Britain from this expedition. And Dominic, we get complaints sometimes, don't we, from Canadian listeners that we don't have enough mentions of Canada on this podcast. But I gather that some of this loot even found its way to the Royal Ontario Museum in Toronto. So that's a lovely little nod to our Canadian
——1868年的阿比西尼亚远征。我认为可以公平地说，这不是一次特别出名的远征，不是那种经典的维多利亚时代远征，但它确实非常震撼。如果你去英国几乎任何一家主要博物馆，比如大英博物馆、大英图书馆、维多利亚与阿尔伯特博物馆、博德利图书馆，你都会发现从这次远征中带回英国的手稿、文物、珠宝或宝藏。多米尼克，我们有时会收到加拿大听众的抱怨，说我们在播客中提到加拿大的次数不够多。但我了解到，这些战利品中甚至有一些流落到了多伦多的皇家安大略博物馆。所以，这算是对我们加拿大听众的一个小小的致意，
Mr. Mark Carney there, because I know he's a big fan of the rest of his history, and he will enjoy that moment. So yeah, those are treasures carried off by British troops after they stormed the mountain citadel of Magdalar to rescue almost 60 European hostages. This emperor, Theodore Tuodros, the second, was holding. And as you say, it's not a terribly well-known Victorian escapade, but it is surely the maddest. So in Sir Harry Flashman's memoirs, he recalls, and I quote, The screaming charge of long-haired warriors swinging their hideous sickle blades
比如马克·卡尼先生，因为我知道他是《余下的历史》的忠实粉丝，他会喜欢这个时刻的。没错，这些都是英国军队在攻占马格达拉山顶堡垒，营救出近60名欧洲人质后掠夺的宝藏。这位皇帝，提奥多罗斯二世，当时正扣押着他们。正如你所说，这不是什么特别出名的维多利亚时代冒险，但绝对是最疯狂的一次。在哈里·弗莱什曼爵士的回忆录中，他回忆道，我引用：‘长发战士挥舞着可怕的镰刀，发出尖叫冲向
against the Sikh bayonets, the huge mound of rotting corpses under the precipice at Islam G. The ghastly forest of crucifixes at Gondar. Who doesn't love a ghastly forest of crucifixes? Right, exactly. Above all, he recalls, and I quote,
锡克教徒的刺刀，伊斯兰吉悬崖下堆积如山的腐烂尸体。贡德尔那令人毛骨悚然的十字架森林。谁不喜欢令人毛骨悚然的十字架森林呢？对，没错。最重要的是，他回忆道，我引用：
The transformation of an urbane, cultivated monarch into a murderous tyrant, shrieking with hysterical glee, as he slashed and hacked at his bound victims. I mean, I don't want to reign on the parade, but obviously this is from a novel. Flashman isn't real. He's an invented character by George McDonnell Fraser
‘一位温文尔雅、受过良好教育的君主变成了一个杀人暴君，当他挥刀砍向被捆绑的受害者时，发出歇斯底里的狂笑。’我的意思是，我不想扫兴，但显然这是小说里的情节。弗莱什曼不是真实存在的。他是乔治·麦克唐纳·弗雷泽虚构的人物，
for the avoidance of any doubt. But how much of this exaggerated? How much is true, do we think? A little bit of it is exaggerated, but there's an awful lot of truth in this. So among the war correspondents, who were embedded with the British troops, the British expedition that went to Magdala.
为了避免任何疑问。但我们认为其中有多少是夸张的？有多少是真实的？有一点夸张，但其中包含大量事实。在随英军嵌入的战地记者中，那支前往马格达拉的英国远征军，
One was Henry Morton-Stanley, and another was the future imperial novelist G.A. Henty. And Henty said this was an expedition to rank alongside the adventures of Enan Cortez and Francisco Pizarro, which we've done on the show. And he's not wrong. Do you think this inspired him in his novels? Because as I remember, I read some of them. Yeah. They were always kind of with Clive to Calcutta, with Hannibal across the Alps, or that kind of stuff.
其中一位是亨利·莫顿·斯坦利，另一位是未来的帝国小说家G.A.亨蒂。亨蒂说，这次远征可以与埃尔南·科尔特斯和弗朗西斯科·皮萨罗的冒险相提并论，我们在节目中讲过他们。他说得没错。你认为这启发了他的小说吗？因为我记得我读过一些。是的。它们总是类似《与克莱夫在加尔各答》、《与汉尼拔翻越阿尔卑斯山》之类的题材。
And it always involved a journey. Yes, completely. Like King Solomon's minds or something. The late Victorians and Edwardians, they love a journey, they love a quest, an expedition. And I think the fact that Henty had been on this incredible, you know, this incredible odyssey into the highlands of Abyssinia from the Red Sea coast, undoubtedly informed his writing. And there is something, there's something terribly tragic about this story, but something really thrilling about it as well. And Abyssinia is Ethiopia. And Ethiopia famously is the country in Africa.
而且总是涉及一段旅程。是的，完全是。就像《所罗门王的宝藏》之类的。维多利亚时代晚期和爱德华时代的人们，他们热爱旅程，热爱探索，热爱远征。我认为亨蒂亲身经历了这次不可思议的、你知道的，这次深入阿比西尼亚高地、从红海海岸出发的奥德赛之旅，无疑影响了他的写作。这个故事里有一些非常悲剧的成分，但也有一些非常令人兴奋的地方。阿比西尼亚就是埃塞俄比亚。众所周知，埃塞俄比亚是非洲国家中
that was never colonized. Yeah, exactly. But interesting that the British do get there even so. Exactly. So, and Tommy, you will know this better than anybody. Well, anybody outside Ethiopia. It's also the second oldest Christian country in the world, isn't it? After Armenia.
唯一从未被殖民过的。是的，完全正确。但有趣的是，英国人即便如此还是到了那里。没错。所以，汤米，你比任何人都清楚这一点。好吧，任何埃塞俄比亚以外的人。它也是世界上第二古老的基督教国家，不是吗？仅次于亚美尼亚。
So I think it embraced Christianity in 330 AD. So when Band-Aid asked, do they know it's Christmas? Yeah, they absolutely know it's Christmas. Absolutely did, yeah. They have done for much longer than we have. But after that, just to give people a sense, So Abyssinia, as it was called in the 19th century, it became effectively cut off from sort of the Mediterranean and the world that became Christendom. And so it became shrouded in mystery.
所以我认为它在公元330年信奉了基督教。所以当“乐队援助”（Band-Aid）问“他们知道现在是圣诞节吗？”时，是的，他们绝对知道现在是圣诞节。绝对知道，是的。他们知道的时间比我们长得多。但在此之后，为了让大家有个概念，阿比西尼亚，正如它在19世纪被称为的那样，实际上与地中海和后来成为基督教世界的地区隔绝了。因此，它笼罩在神秘之中。
And people in sort of medieval Europe used to love the idea of Presta John, didn't they? This kind of lost Christian king who might be in India or he might be in somewhere in Africa. And, you know, people have often wondered whether this was some sort of buried ancestral memory of this. lost Christian realm of Abyssinia. Anyway, in the 1520s, the Portuguese turned up. It's always the Portuguese. And then for the next few centuries, very slowly the outside world intrudes on this kind of mountain kingdom. So you have the Ottomans who are on the Red Sea. And then the early 19th century, the Egyptians, so the Egyptians are sort of pushing up the Nile through Sudan. And both of these powers are Muslim. And Ethiopia, obviously, is Christian. So that's adding a
中世纪欧洲的人们过去常常喜欢“祭司王约翰”的想法，不是吗？这种可能在印度或非洲某处的失落的基督教国王。而且，你知道，人们经常怀疑这是否是某种关于阿比西尼亚这个失落的基督教王国的祖先记忆。总之，在16世纪20年代，葡萄牙人出现了。总是葡萄牙人。接下来的几个世纪里，外部世界非常缓慢地侵入了这种山地王国。所以你有红海上的奥斯曼人。然后是19世纪初的埃及人，埃及人正沿着尼罗河穿过苏丹向南推进。这两个势力都是穆斯林。而埃塞俄比亚显然是基督教国家。所以这增加了一个
further dimension of tension. Exactly. So there's a strain of nativism that runs through this story, I think, of nationalism, I suppose, and a fear of encirclement by Muslim powers and a fear that other Christians, heretical Christians, will sell them out. Well, we did an episode on the Ark of the Covenant, which Ethiopia claims to have, and the Ethiopian royal family claimed descent from Solomon and the Queen of Sheba. So they have, you know, they have very, very deep links to the kind of the mythology of the Bible in a way that no other Christian kingdom does. Exactly. And they feel, well, they feel they own the story. And other people are newcomers and parvenus and so on. Anyway, let's kick off in 1843. So 1843, this young
进一步的紧张维度。没错。所以我认为这个故事中贯穿着一种本土主义，我想是民族主义，以及对被穆斯林势力包围的恐惧，还有对其他基督徒——异端基督徒——会出卖他们的恐惧。好吧，我们做过一期关于约柜的节目，埃塞俄比亚声称拥有它，而且埃塞俄比亚皇室声称是所罗门和示巴女王的后裔。所以他们有，你知道，他们与圣经神话有着非常、非常深厚的联系，这是其他基督教王国所没有的。没错。而且他们觉得，嗯，他们觉得他们拥有这个故事。而其他人是后来者和暴发户等等。总之，让我们从1843年开始。所以1843年，这位年轻的
British visitor arrives in Abyssinian. His name is Walter Plowden and he's 23 years old. Plowden was born in India to a civil service family. But he's a kind of restless, adventurous sort of a young man. He's eager to see action. And he was going back to England when he stopped in Suez and he met a Scottish sailor called John Bell. And John Bell said to him, you know, I've always had this dream of going to look for the source of the White Nile. And Plowden said, brilliant, why don't we do it? I'll come along. Yeah, because that's a peak Victorian activity. It is. So they set off, they went south. They went into the mountains of Abyssinia and they absolutely loved it. And this guy Plowden, he wrote about it afterwards. He said it's absolutely
英国访客抵达了阿比西尼亚。他的名字叫沃尔特·普劳登，当时23岁。普劳登出生在印度的公务员家庭。但他是一个不安分、爱冒险的年轻人。他渴望看到行动。他正要回英国时，在苏伊士停了下来，遇到了一个叫约翰·贝尔的苏格兰水手。约翰·贝尔对他说，你知道，我一直有个梦想，去寻找白尼罗河的源头。普劳登说，太棒了，为什么我们不一起去呢？是的，因为那是典型的维多利亚时代活动。确实。所以他们出发了，向南走。他们进入了阿比西尼亚的山区，并且非常喜欢那里。这个叫普劳登的家伙，后来写了关于它的文章。他说这绝对是
brilliant. It's basically like going back in time to the high Middle Ages. It's warlords, its feasts, it's battles, it's chivalry. He says, you know, life in Britain and in Western Europe now is very boring and industrial and suburban. But this is fantastic. There is no parallel to it, he said, in this steaming and telegraphing world. Well, the steam and the steamship and the telegraph and the railway of things we'll be talking about in a little while. So they went into Abyssinia, Belle married an Abyssinian woman and became a kind of military officer in Abyssinia, and Plowton had all kinds of mad adventures and escapades and captures and escapes. And eventually he decided to go back to England. Inevitably, he was shipwrecked in the Red Sea,
太棒了。基本上就像回到了中世纪盛期。有军阀、盛宴、战斗、骑士精神。他说，你知道，英国和西欧现在的生活非常无聊、工业化和郊区化。但这太棒了。他说，在这个蒸汽和电报的世界里，没有与之相比的东西。好吧，蒸汽、蒸汽船、电报和铁路是我们稍后会谈论的事情。所以他们进入了阿比西尼亚，贝尔娶了一位阿比西尼亚女子，成为了阿比西尼亚的一名军官，而普劳登经历了各种疯狂的冒险、逃亡、被捕和脱险。最终他决定回英国。不可避免地，他在红海遭遇了海难，
but finally he got back and in 1848 he was appointed by the Foreign Office as Britain's first consul at a place called Masawa, which is a Red Sea port. It's now in Eritrea, and Masawa was basically the gateway from the... the sea into this landlocked kingdom of Abyssinia. And Plowton's great dream, he's a huge, I don't know if this is a word, Abyssinia file, and his dream is to arrange a permanent treaty that will cement Anglo-Aborinian friendship. The problem is that Abyssinia is very turbulent.
但最终他回到了英国，并在1848年被外交部任命为英国驻马萨瓦的首任领事，那是一个红海港口。它现在位于厄立特里亚，马萨瓦基本上是从海洋进入阿比西尼亚这个内陆王国的门户。普劳登的伟大梦想，他是一个巨大的——我不知道这算不算一个词——“阿比西尼亚迷”，他的梦想是达成一项永久条约，巩固英阿友谊。问题是阿比西尼亚非常动荡。
It's basically locked into this permanent Wars of the Roses. So you already mentioned there's an ancient dynasty that is descended from Solomon and therefore from David, but they have basically become powerless. And it's this huge infighting between warlords and pretenders and kingmakers and different kind of provincial strongmen and whatnot. Impossible to follow. And perhaps as a result, as a reaction to this instability, there is a tradition in Abyssinia by the 19th century that a Messiah descended from Solomon and David will one day arise. He will crush all his rivals. He will unite this fractured country.
它基本上陷入了永久的“玫瑰战争”。所以你已经提到有一个古老的王朝，是所罗门和大卫的后裔，因此他们基本上已经变得无能为力。军阀、觊觎者、造王者和各种省份强人之间存在着巨大的内斗。根本无法理清。也许正因为如此，作为对这种不稳定的反应，阿比西尼亚在19世纪有一种传统，即一位所罗门和大卫的后裔、弥赛亚终有一天会出现。他将粉碎所有对手。他将统一这个破碎的国家。
He will wipe the floor with their enemies, the Egyptians. and he will march all the way to Jerusalem to restore the true faith in the holy city. And tradition has it that his name will be Teodros, Theodore, the gift of God. And there are occasionally kind of false Theodors, false Teodroses, but none of them kind of stick. And then, in March 1855, Plowden sends a message to the foreign office in London. He says, there is at last some chance that Abyssinia may be unisonable. knighted under one sovereign and such a one as shall merit the support and friendship of her majesty's government. And the bloke he's talking about is a man called Kasa, who's from the north of
他将把他们的敌人——埃及人——打得落花流水。他将一路进军耶路撒冷，在圣城恢复真正的信仰。传统认为他的名字将是提奥多罗斯（Teodros），即西奥多（Theodore），上帝的礼物。偶尔会有一些假西奥多、假提奥多罗斯出现，但没有一个能站稳脚跟。然后，在1855年3月，普劳登向伦敦外交部发送了一条消息。他说，阿比西尼亚终于有了一些统一的希望，在一位君主统治下，这样的人值得女王政府的支持和友谊。他所说的那个家伙是一个叫卡萨（Kasa）的人，他来自
Abyssinia. And what we know of this guy, Casa, he was born in 1818 or thereabouts, so he's probably in his mid-30s at this point. He has an obscure background. He seems to have been educated in a monastery, which was attacked by bandits, and then he escaped. He became an outlaw himself, a kind of bandit leader. But no hint, no hint that he's descended from a biblical king. No, at this point, no hint that he's descended from Solomon. Although, of course, he will claim dissent from Solomon later, of course. So Kasa is a sort of bold, courageous, charismatic man. He's obviously a good leader of men. He beats one rival after another in the 1840s, early 1850s. Then in January 1855, he beats his last major rival and he assembles all his troops and he says,
阿比西尼亚北部。关于这个叫卡萨的家伙，我们知道他出生于1818年左右，所以此时他大概30多岁。他出身卑微。他似乎是在一座修道院受的教育，修道院遭到土匪袭击，然后他逃了出来。他自己也成了亡命之徒，一种土匪头子。但没有任何迹象，没有任何迹象表明他是圣经中国王的后裔。不，此时没有任何迹象表明他是所罗门的后裔。尽管当然，他后来会声称自己是所罗门的后裔。所以卡萨是一个大胆、勇敢、有魅力的人。他显然是一个优秀的领导者。他在19世纪40年代、50年代初击败了一个又一个对手。然后在1855年1月，他击败了最后一个主要对手，召集了他所有的军队，他说，
I'm the new emperor of Abyssinia and to mark the occasion I am taking a new name and that name is Teodros. So he is Teodros the second, isn't he? And I was thinking, well, who was Teodros the first? So I did some detailed research in the Bodleian. Did he? In the Bodle Library?
我是阿比西尼亚的新皇帝，为了纪念这个时刻，我将采用一个新的名字，那个名字就是提奥多罗斯。所以他是提奥多罗斯二世，对吧？我在想，那么提奥多罗斯一世是谁？所以我做了一些详细的研究，在博德利图书馆。他做了吗？在博德利图书馆？
Yeah, he's kind of King Arthur figure who reigned around the same time that Henry V was winning the Battle of Agincourt for about nine months. And James Bruce, an explorer in the 19th century, He said there must have been something very brilliant that happened under this prince, but no one can remember what it is. Yeah. So, anyway, this guy, Kasa, now Teotros, is the protagonist of our story.
是的，他是一个类似亚瑟王的人物，统治时间大约在亨利五世赢得阿金库尔战役的时候，统治了大约九个月。詹姆斯·布鲁斯，19世纪的一位探险家，他说这位王子统治下一定发生过非常辉煌的事情，但没人记得是什么了。是的。总之，这个叫卡萨，现在叫提奥多罗斯的人，是我们故事的主角。
Flashman, you may recall, called him a murderous tyrant shrieking with hysterical glee. And Alan Moorhead, who wrote two brilliant books on the history of the Nile, said he has a reputation in the historiography of a mad dog let loose, a sort of black reincarnation of Ivan the terrible. But I think this is very unfair. because actually when Plowton first visited this guy's camp, Teodros liked to spend a lot of time on campaign, so he was always intense. He visits his camp in summer 1855, and he's actually very impressed by Teodros.
弗莱什曼，你可能还记得，称他为“发出歇斯底里狂笑的杀人暴君”。而写了两本关于尼罗河历史的杰出著作的艾伦·穆尔黑德说，他在史学界的名声是一个被放出来的疯狗，一种伊凡雷帝的黑色转世。但我认为这非常不公平。因为实际上当普劳登第一次访问这个家伙的营地时，提奥多罗斯喜欢花很多时间在战场上，所以他总是很紧张。他在1855年夏天访问了他的营地，实际上对提奥多罗斯印象非常深刻。
He finds him kind of reclining on a divan, surrounded by musicians playing flutes and banging drums. So very kind of, this is absolute, you know, European meeting Indigenous king bingo. Reclining on a divan is pretty much obligatory, isn't it? Obligatory, exactly. And actually in his report to the Foreign Office, he said this guy is very charming and very impressive. He's young, he's vigorous, he's polite and engaging when pleased, and mostly displaying great tact and delicacy.
他发现他躺在沙发上，周围是吹着笛子、敲着鼓的音乐家。所以非常，你知道，这是典型的“欧洲人遇见土著国王”的桥段。躺在沙发上几乎是必须的，不是吗？必须的，没错。实际上在他给外交部的报告中，他说这个家伙非常迷人，非常令人印象深刻。他年轻、精力充沛、礼貌且引人入胜，当他高兴时，大多表现出极大的机智和细腻。
He said, Teodros is very dedicated to the idea of restoring the glories of the Ethiopian Empire and achieving great conquests. He's man of untiring energy. His personal and moral daring is boundless. Now, there are a couple of flaws that Plowden notes as well. his violent anger at times, his unyielding pride as regards his kingly and divine right, and his fanatical religious zeal. However, Plowden says this is a man we can do business with. He wants to reclaim Abyssinia's ancient borders. He dreams of retaking Egypt for Christianity, marching all the way to Cairo and Alexandria, and then, and I quote, a triumphant march to the holy sepulchre. Can I ask, the foreign office in London wouldn't necessarily approve of these? goals, would they? I think they're mad goals. Because this, of course, is the period when they're
他说，提奥多罗斯非常致力于恢复埃塞俄比亚帝国的荣耀并取得伟大征服的想法。他是一个不知疲倦的人。他个人的和道德上的胆识是无限的。现在，普劳登也注意到了一些缺陷：他有时暴怒，他对自己作为国王和神圣权利的不可动摇的骄傲，以及他狂热的宗教热情。然而，普劳登说这是一个我们可以与之做生意的人。他想收回阿比西尼亚的古老边界。他梦想着为基督教夺回埃及，一路进军开罗和亚历山大，然后，我引用，‘凯旋进军圣墓’。我可以问一下，伦敦的外交部不一定会批准这些目标，对吧？我认为这些是疯狂的目标。因为这当然是他们
starting to think about a Suez Canal. They don't want to offend the Ottomans. No, they don't want to offend the Ottomans particularly with whom they, of course, they're allied in the Crimean War. I mean, British interests in Egypt are extremely important to them. They do not want to alienate the Egyptians, and this, as we'll see, becomes a problem. So on top of that, Britain is Christian power, Ethiopia is the Christian power? Is there any sense that, therefore, they are natural allies? Or is Britain simply, it's all about real politics? It's all about imperial priorities. The Christian element just doesn't really enter the calculations of diplomats in London.
开始考虑苏伊士运河的时期。他们不想冒犯奥斯曼人。不，他们不想冒犯奥斯曼人，特别是他们当然在克里米亚战争中与他们结盟。我的意思是，英国在埃及的利益对他们来说极其重要。他们不想疏远埃及人，正如我们将看到的，这成了一个问题。最重要的是，英国是基督教大国，埃塞俄比亚是基督教大国？有没有一种感觉，因此他们是天然的盟友？还是英国纯粹是现实政治？这完全是关于帝国优先事项。基督教因素并没有真正进入伦敦外交官的计算中。
It's important to some people. It's definitely important to Plowton. It's important, as we will see, to lots of missionaries and missionary organizations. But not to the government. But to the government, I would argue, probably not. I think they certainly have religious prejudices, but there's an awful lot of realpolitik in this, as we will find out. Anyway, Plowden says to Tildros, would you like to some? a treaty with Britain and Teodros hesitates. What he doesn't want to do is sign a treaty that would
这对某些人很重要。这对普劳登来说绝对很重要。正如我们将看到的，这对许多传教士和传教组织来说很重要。但对政府来说呢？但对政府，我会说，可能不是。我认为他们肯定有宗教偏见，但其中有大量的现实政治，正如我们将发现的那样。总之，普劳登对提奥多罗斯说，你想和英国签订条约吗？提奥多罗斯犹豫了。他不想做的是签署一项条约，
give British agents in Abyssinia diplomatic immunity. He says, you know, my word is law and anything that undermines our sovereignty I'm not happy with. So I don't really want to sign a treaty with you actually. And Plowton thinks, well, fine, maybe he'll come around in time. And actually, Teotros doesn't seem like a terrible investment. So Flashman paints him as this, you know, demonic kind of drunken maniac. But there are lots of ways in which he's actually quite forward thinking. He's a would-be moderniser, actually. He wants to stamp out the power of the regional warlords. He wants to build a new road network. He wants a new system of royal justice. You could see him as a sort of Henry the 7th or something, you know, wanting to impose order after years of chaos.
给予英国在阿比西尼亚的代理人外交豁免权。他说，你知道，我的话就是法律，任何削弱我们主权的事情我都不高兴。所以我真的不想和你签条约。普劳登想，好吧，也许他以后会想通的。实际上，提奥多罗斯看起来并不像一个糟糕的投资。所以弗莱什曼把他描绘成一个恶魔般的、醉醺醺的疯子。但在很多方面，他实际上是相当有前瞻性的。他实际上是一个想成为现代化者的人。他想铲除地方军阀的权力。他想建立一个新的道路网络。他想要一个新的皇家司法系统。你可以把他看作是亨利七世之类的人，你知道，想在多年混乱后强加秩序。
He wants to fight slavery because, of course, the slave trade across the Red Sea and the Indian Ocean is controlled by his Muslim rivals. And is that a kind of a gesture of economic warfare against the Ottomans or is there any humanitarian impulsar at all? That is a hard thing to say because although we know of we don't really have that much insights into his inner world, I suspect there's an awful lot of kind of political expediency in it, frankly. He also wants very Peter the Great-like. He wants to change the way people dress. So he wants Abyssinians to wear proper clothes. He wants the them to wear shirts with special coloured sleeves if they've done great service to the state.
他想打击奴隶制，因为当然，跨越红海和印度洋的奴隶贸易是由他的穆斯林对手控制的。这是一种针对奥斯曼人的经济战姿态，还是有任何人道主义冲动？这很难说，因为虽然我们知道，我们并没有真正深入了解他的内心世界，但我怀疑其中有大量的政治权宜之计，坦率地说。他还非常像彼得大帝。他想改变人们的着装方式。所以他想让阿比西尼亚人穿得体的衣服。他想让他们穿袖子上有特殊颜色的衬衫，如果他们为国家做出了巨大贡献的话。
So that's nice. And he's absolutely fascinated by the outside world. So he loves meeting travellers. He loves hearing about Britain and France. He's obsessed with the Crimean War. That's something that will be coming up on the rest of his history before the end of the year, isn't it? We'll be doing a series about the Crimean War. So Teodros would have loved that because when travellers come, he always sort of says,
这很好。而且他绝对被外部世界所吸引。所以他喜欢见旅行者。他喜欢听关于英国和法国的事情。他痴迷于克里米亚战争。那是《余下的历史》在年底前会提到的事情，不是吗？我们将做一个关于克里米亚战争的系列。所以提奥多罗斯会喜欢那个，因为当旅行者来的时候，他总是会说，
what news from Balaclava? Tell me of Sebastopol. You know, he can't wait to get all this sort of stuff. Doesn't he end up having a gun called Sebastopol in due course? He does. His favourite possession, a gun called Sebastopol. So it really has had an impact on him. Yes.
巴拉克拉瓦有什么消息？告诉我塞瓦斯托波尔的情况。你知道，他迫不及待地想得到所有这些东西。他后来不是有一门叫“塞瓦斯托波尔”的炮吗？他有。他最喜欢的财产，一门叫“塞瓦斯托波尔”的炮。所以它确实对他产生了影响。是的。
But the Crimean way fascinates him and bewilders him. He cannot get his head around the fact that Christian Britain and France are allied with Muslim, the Muslim Turkey, the Ottoman Empire, against another Christian power, Russia. He really struggles to comprehend that and that makes him wonder whether the British are quite as devoted to Christianity as they should be. Anyway, a year later, end of 1856, he has the highest ranking visitor he would ever receive
但克里米亚战争让他着迷又困惑。他无法理解基督教的英国和法国竟然与穆斯林土耳其、奥斯曼帝国结盟，去对抗另一个基督教大国俄罗斯。他真的很难理解这一点，这让他怀疑英国人是否像他们应该的那样忠于基督教。总之，一年后，1856年底，他接待了他有史以来最高级别的访客，
and this is the Coptic patriarch Cyril IV who is the sort of spiritual father of the Ethiopian church and he comes to visit from Alexandria and Cyril turns up and he is very, very down on Abyssinia and Renegis practice Cyril says, look, you have far too many holidays, holy days. You have far too many saints and they're all wrong. Your calendar is bonkers, all of this. And Teodros, he's completely conforms to Plowden's picture of him because he,
这就是科普特牧首西里尔四世，他是埃塞俄比亚教会的精神之父，他从亚历山大来访。西里尔出现了，他非常、非常看不起阿比西尼亚的习俗。西里尔说，看，你们的节日、圣日太多了。你们的圣徒太多了，而且他们都错了。你们的历法是荒唐的，所有这些。而提奥多罗斯，他完全符合普劳登对他的描述，因为他，
Proudon said he was very hot-tempered and proud. He goes, ballistic at this, he locks up the patriarch for a little while, and the rumours sweep Abyssinia, well, Teodros has fallen under the sway of the English. Maybe he's going to convert to Protestantism. And he doesn't. Eventually he releases this patriarch and he kneels to ask his forgiveness. And he says, I'm sorry, I've locked you up. And Cyril says, the problem of the years you've been listening to English visitors, don't trust the English. They're only pretending to be your friends. They are plotting, and I quote, to undermine your power and conquer your country.
普劳登说他脾气暴躁且骄傲。他疯了，他把牧首关了一段时间，谣言席卷了阿比西尼亚，好吧，提奥多罗斯已经落入了英国人的控制之下。也许他要皈依新教了。但他没有。最终他释放了这位牧首，并跪下请求他的宽恕。他说，对不起，我把你关起来了。西里尔说，这些年来你一直听信英国访客的问题，不要相信英国人。他们只是假装是你的朋友。他们正在密谋，我引用，‘削弱你的权力并征服你的国家’。
Which they're not, to be fair to the English. No, which they're not, which they're absolutely not. But this is a thread that will run through this story. I think because the Abyssinians have been so isolated for so long, they have got it into their heads that their neighbors are all plotting to sell them out or undermine. or undermine them or conquer them or whatever. I suppose to be fair to him. I mean, the British do have a certain track record in. They do.
而他们并没有，对英国人来说公平点。不，他们没有，他们绝对没有。但这将是贯穿这个故事的一条线索。我认为因为阿比西尼亚人被孤立了太久，他们已经认定他们的邻居都在密谋出卖他们，或者削弱他们，或者征服他们等等。我想对他公平点。我的意思是，英国人确实有一定的记录。他们确实有。
Well, I mean, at this point, if you listen to the French, they do. But Teodros is actually still quite devoted to the British. He still crazed their approval. He recognises that they're the most powerful, the richest, the most modern country on earth. And so when the patriarch leaves, he takes with him two letters. And one of them was dictated by Teodros himself. And this was a letter dictated to quix. Queen Victoria. May this letter sent by the King of Kings Teodros of Ethiopia reach the Queen of England, Victoria.
好吧，我的意思是，在这一点上，如果你听法国人的，他们确实有。但提奥多罗斯实际上仍然相当忠于英国人。他仍然渴望他们的认可。他承认他们是地球上最强大、最富有、最现代的国家。所以当牧首离开时，他带走了两封信。其中一封是由提奥多罗斯本人口述的。这是写给维多利亚女王的信。愿这封由埃塞俄比亚万王之王提奥多罗斯寄出的信到达英国女王维多利亚手中。
How are you? Are you well? I am well, thank God. I have received your envoy with love and friendship. Now you are the child of Christ and I am the child of Christ. For the love of Christ, I want friendship. So that's nice. That's a great letter. It's a fantastic letter. How are you? Are you well? I'm well. I love it. I think he's my favourite Abyssinian King. It's basically like a cold call from a call centre, isn't it? How are you? How's your day going? No, it's not. It's like a pen pal. Yes, that's what it's like. So the other letter is from Plowden to the Foreign Office. And Plowden says, I think we should cement the relationship with Ebassinia.
你好吗？你还好吗？我很好，感谢上帝。我怀着爱和友谊收到了你的特使。现在你是基督的孩子，我也是基督的孩子。为了基督的爱，我想要友谊。所以这很好。这是一封很棒的信。你好吗？你还好吗？我很好。我喜欢它。我想他是我最喜欢的阿比西尼亚国王。这基本上就像来自呼叫中心的冷呼叫，不是吗？你好吗？你今天过得怎么样？不，不是。这就像笔友。是的，就是这样。所以另一封信是普劳登写给外交部的。普劳登说，我认为我们应该巩固与阿比西尼亚的关系。
Could you please send Teodros some guns and ammunition and a handsome piece for his own use, like a hunting rifle? This is in 1857 and two years go by and Plowden and Teodros hear nothing back. And then at last, Plowden gets a message from the coast. London of sent him a package. What is it? There's a rifle, a screwdriver and a case. It's unclear whether the case is for the rifle or the screwdriver. It's for the screwdriver.
你们能给提奥多罗斯送些枪支弹药和一件供他个人使用的精美武器吗，比如猎枪？这是在1857年，两年过去了，普劳登和提奥多罗斯什么回音也没收到。然后终于，普劳登从海岸收到了一条消息。伦敦给他寄了一个包裹。是什么？有一把步枪、一把螺丝刀和一个盒子。不清楚盒子是给步枪的还是给螺丝刀的。是给螺丝刀的。
And that is it. And his heart sinks because he knows this won't go down well with your dross. Not even a letter. And the truth is, of course, the foreign office don't really care. Abyssinia is like a massive backwater. No one really cares about it. It's also they've had the Indian mutiny raging, haven't they? So they've had other things on their mind.
就是这样。他的心沉了下去，因为他知道这在提奥多罗斯那里不会有好结果。甚至连一封信都没有。事实当然是，外交部根本不在乎。阿比西尼亚就像一个巨大的死水。没人真正在乎它。而且他们还经历了印度兵变，不是吗？所以他们有其他事情要考虑。
They've got other things on their mind. Anyway, time goes by. Teodros gets on with fighting the kind of regional warlords and trying to unite the kingdom. But it's much bloodier and more grueling than he expected. He stamps out one rebellion, another breaks out in the next door province. And at one point he says to Plowden, I have deceived myself. This is a stiff-necked people.
他们有其他事情要考虑。总之，时间流逝。提奥多罗斯继续与地方军阀作战，试图统一王国。但这比他预期的要血腥和艰苦得多。他平定了一场叛乱，邻近省份又爆发了另一场。有一次他对普劳登说，我欺骗了自己。这是一群顽固的人。
And it is necessary to chastise them before they enjoy the blessings which Providence has intended. He speaks always in this very kind of rolling biblical cadences. And then in 1858, a key moment, I think, his wife, who was always a moderating influence on him, it was called Tewabak. She died in her late 20s, and he was absolutely bereft. He married again for political reasons.
在他们享受天意所预定的祝福之前，有必要惩罚他们。他说话总是带着这种非常滚动的圣经韵律。然后是1858年，一个关键时刻，我想，他一直作为他温和影响力的妻子，叫特瓦巴克（Tewabak），她在20多岁时去世了，他完全悲痛欲绝。他为了政治原因再次结婚。
He married a woman called Tiranesh. I say a woman, she was 12, and they didn't really get on. Whenever Teodros went to her tent, he would find her reading the Psalms, and she would just say to him very coldly, curtly, I'm conversing with a greater king than you. Get out. He clearly finds this distressing because he starts drinking very heavily at around this point. He starts sleeping with random
他娶了一个叫蒂拉内什（Tiranesh）的女人。我说女人，她才12岁，他们相处得并不好。每当提奥多罗斯去她的帐篷时，他都会发现她在读《诗篇》，她会非常冷淡、生硬地对他说，‘我正在与一位比你更伟大的国王交谈。出去。’他显然觉得这很令人痛苦，因为他从这时开始酗酒非常严重。他开始与营地里的随机
women in the camp. And he confesses to visiting European missionaries. He says, I'm leading a very unchristian and just reputable life. And he feels bad about it. So there's that. Now the second key moment is in 1860, two years later. Plowden, his friend, is traveling across Abyssinia when his party is ambushed by rebels. Plowden is wounded. with a spear and he dies nine days later. So that's the end of him. He had an exciting time, but it ended prematurely. But I guess it's the way he would have wanted to go.
女性发生关系。他向访问的欧洲传教士忏悔。他说，我过着非常不基督徒且名声不佳的生活。他对此感到难过。所以就是这样。现在第二个关键时刻是在1860年，两年后。普劳登，他的朋友，在穿越阿比西尼亚时，他的队伍遭到叛军伏击。普劳登被长矛刺伤，九天后去世。所以这就是他的结局。他度过了一段激动人心的时光，但过早地结束了。但我猜这正是他想要的方式。
It is exactly. Absolutely it is. So the British now need to appoint a new representative on the Red Sea coast. Again, it's not a priority for them. So it takes them two years to finally send somebody out. And during that time, Teodros' mental state declines from bad to worse. So missionaries who are writing back say he's increasing vengeful and angry. He's like a man on the verge of a titanic explosion. And part of this is
确实。绝对是。所以英国人现在需要在红海海岸任命一位新的代表。同样，这对他们来说不是优先事项。所以他们花了两年时间才最终派人出去。在此期间，提奥多罗斯的精神状态从糟糕变得更糟。所以写信回来的传教士说他变得越来越复仇心重和愤怒。他就像一个处于巨大爆炸边缘的人。而这部分是
obviously, you know, contextual. Abyssinia is a very violent place. There are constant uprisings. There's also, I think, a slight degree of paranoia. He's terrified that the British are conspiring, as we said, with the Ottomans and with the Egyptians. He's obsessed with the idea that people in his entourage are plotting against him. So he will regularly hold purges of his senior officers and he would cut off their hands and feet or sometimes just one hand and one foot and then he'd throw them outside to be devoured by hyenas. That's a horrible fate.
显然，你知道，背景性的。阿比西尼亚是一个非常暴力的地方。不断有起义。我认为还有一点偏执。他害怕英国人正如我们所说，在与奥斯曼人和埃及人密谋。他痴迷于他随从中的人正在密谋反对他的想法。所以他会定期清洗他的高级军官，他会砍掉他们的手脚，或者有时只是一只手和一只脚，然后把他们扔到外面去喂鬣狗。那是一个可怕的命运。
So there's that. We already encountered him saying to Plowden, you know, the people of Eversignia are rather letting me down. And he really comes to believe this. When he goes into rebel provinces, he's increasingly merciless. He calls himself the flail of the wicked. And he likes to quote one of the Psalms, the righteous shall rejoice when he seeth the vengeance,
所以就是这样。我们已经遇到他告诉普劳登，你知道，阿比西尼亚的人民确实让我失望了。他真的开始相信这一点。当他进入叛乱省份时，他越来越冷酷无情。他称自己为“邪恶者的连枷”。他喜欢引用《诗篇》中的一句，‘义人见仇敌遭报，就欢喜，’
he shall wash his feet in the blood of the wicked. Washing his feet in the blood of the wicked is very much what Teodras is about by the 1860s. And in order to do this, he's become particularly obsessed with guns. No one in history, not even the people who go to your brother and Alma's festival, their World War II festival, not even those people are as interested in artillery as this guy. He loves guns. he has turned to a group of Swiss and German missionaries who had settled in a place called Gefat in northern Abyssinia
‘要在恶人的血中洗脚。’到19世纪60年代，在恶人的血中洗脚正是提奥多罗斯所做的事情。为了做到这一点，他变得特别痴迷于枪支。历史上没有人，甚至连去你兄弟和阿尔玛节、他们的二战节的人，甚至那些人对火炮的兴趣都不如这个家伙。他喜欢枪。他转向了一群定居在阿比西尼亚北部一个叫格法特（Gefat）地方的瑞士和德国传教士，
and he had allowed these missionaries in because they had presented themselves as craftsmen. They've said, or we'd like to teach interesting transferable skills to the Abyssinian people. And they'd built huts and a water wheel and a school and all this kind of thing. I mean, that's missionary kind of activity, isn't it?
他允许这些传教士进入，因为他们把自己表现为工匠。他们说，或者我们想教阿比西尼亚人民有趣的、可转移的技能。他们建造了小屋、水车、学校和所有这些东西。我的意思是，那是传教士的活动，不是吗？
Yeah, missionaries are always building water wheels. They love that kind of thing. But building artillery is, is less of a missionary activity, I would guess. Exactly. He loves this one bloke who's Swiss called Theophilus Waldmeier, who apparently is very good at mending muskets, very good with his hands.
是的，传教士总是建造水车。他们喜欢那种东西。但我猜建造火炮是传教士较少的活动。没错。他喜欢这个叫西奥菲勒斯·瓦尔德迈尔（Theophilus Waldmeier）的瑞士家伙，他显然非常擅长修理火枪，非常擅长手工。
And he's always on to this guy, Valdmeier. Can you not build me a massive cannon? And over time, he says to these sort of German-speaking Swiss missionaries, could you please build me bigger and bigger guns? And he gets them to build blast furnaces and things. This is the conditions of them staying in his country. And the blast furnaces keep exploding. because actually ultimately they're not gunsmiths, they're missionaries.
他总是缠着这个家伙，瓦尔德迈尔。你不能给我造一门巨大的大炮吗？随着时间的推移，他对这些讲德语的瑞士传教士说，你们能给我造越来越大的枪吗？他让他们建造高炉之类的东西。这是他们留在他的国家的条件。而高炉不断爆炸，因为实际上他们最终不是枪匠，他们是传教士。
No. It's a big ask if you've never done it before. Deodorus is very impatient. And he says to them, I want you to build me bigger guns. And I quote, if you say you don't know how, I shall regard you as liars and you know what I do with those who deceive me.
不。如果你以前从未做过，这是一个很大的要求。提奥多罗斯非常不耐烦。他对他们说，我要你们给我造更大的枪。我引用，‘如果你说你不知道怎么做，我将视你们为骗子，你们知道我怎么对待那些欺骗我的人。’
Oh dear. So that is ominous for these men of God. And it's against this background that the British finally appoint their new envoy. And he is a man called Captain. Charles Duncan Cameron and he rides into Teodros' camp in October 1862. And Cameron is a career soldier he had served
哦，天哪。所以这对这些上帝的仆人来说是不祥的。正是在这种背景下，英国人终于任命了他们的新特使。他是一个叫查尔斯·邓肯·卡梅伦（Charles Duncan Cameron）上尉的人，他在1862年10月骑马进入了提奥多罗斯的营地。卡梅伦是一名职业军人，他曾在
in South Africa and indeed in the Crimea before coming to Masawa on the Red Sea coast. And when he arrives he has a present for Teodros its two dueling pistols with a silver inscription. Presented to Theodore Emperor of Abyssinia by a Victoria
南非服役，实际上在来到红海海岸的马萨瓦之前还在克里米亚服役。当他到达时，他给提奥多罗斯带了一份礼物，两把带有银色铭文的决斗手枪。‘赠予阿比西尼亚皇帝提奥多罗斯，由维多利亚女王，
Queen of Great Britain and Ireland for his kindness to her servant Plowden. Now these pistols are important, we will come back to them later. They will have an ironic function. It's great to have some dueling pistols back on the show after Alexander Hamilton. Exactly. So Cameron, he's the new guy, career soldier. He is not as pro-Abecinea as Plowdon. He's sort of stiff. He's a bit inflexible. He's shocked by Teodros's bloodthirstiness. When Teodros goes into his rants about launching a holy war against the Egyptians,
大不列颠及爱尔兰女王，感谢他对她的仆人普劳登的善意。’现在这些手枪很重要，我们稍后会回到它们。它们将有一个讽刺的功能。在亚历山大·汉密尔顿之后，节目里又能有决斗手枪真是太好了。没错。所以卡梅伦，他是新人，职业军人。他不像普劳登那样亲阿比西尼亚。他有点僵硬。他有点不灵活。他对提奥多罗斯的嗜血感到震惊。当提奥多罗斯开始咆哮要对埃及人发动圣战时，
this guy Captain Cameron just sort of frowns and looks a bit pained because he knows this is bonkers. Had Plowden kind of said, yeah, that's great, Your Majesty. Exactly. Plowden had been like planning the pageantry or something. With apt biblical quotes. Exactly. And so now we get to a key moment in the story. Towards the end of 1862, Cameron leaves the camp to go back to the Red Sea coast.
这位卡梅伦上尉只是皱着眉头，看起来有点痛苦，因为他知道这太疯狂了。普劳登以前会说，‘是的，那太棒了，陛下。’没错。普劳登会像是在策划盛大的场面之类的。带着恰当的圣经引语。没错。所以现在我们到了故事的一个关键时刻。1862年底，卡梅伦离开营地返回红海海岸。
And to Odros gives him a letter. And the letter reads as follows, In the name of the father of the son and of the Holy Ghost, one God in Trinity, chosen by God, King of Kings, Teodros of Ethiopia, to Her Majesty, Victoria, Queen of England. Mr. Plowden used to tell me that there was a great Christian queen who loves all Christians. I was prevented by the Turks occupying the sea coast from sending you an embassy when I was in difficulty. Consul Cameron arrived with the letter and presence of friendship. By the power of God,
而提奥多罗斯给了他一封信。信的内容如下：‘以圣父、圣子、圣灵之名，三位一体的上帝，上帝所选，埃塞俄比亚万王之王提奥多罗斯，致英国女王维多利亚陛下。普劳登先生过去常告诉我，有一位伟大的基督教女王，她爱所有的基督徒。我因土耳其人占领海岸而无法在困难时向你派遣使团。卡梅伦领事带着友谊的信件和礼物抵达。靠着上帝的力量，’
I was very glad. I've received your presence and I thank you much. Now, I wish that you may arrange for the safe passage of my ambassadors everywhere on the road. I wish to have an answer to this letter by Consul Cameron and that he may conduct my embassy to England see how Islam oppresses the Christians. This is the letter. Cameron goes off with the letter and weeks go by and then months
我非常高兴。我已经收到了您的到来，我非常感谢。现在，我希望您能安排我的大使在路上的安全通行。我希望卡梅伦领事能带回这封信的答复，并希望他能带领我的使团前往英国，看看伊斯兰教是如何压迫基督徒的。这就是这封信。卡梅伦带着信离开了，几周过去了，然后几个月
go by and Cameron finally returns in June 1863 so this is about six months later. And Teodros says, has your mistress the Queen of England? Gosh has she written me a reply? And Cameron says, unfortunately I've heard nothing I've had nothing from London.
过去了，卡梅伦终于在1863年6月回来了，也就是大约六个月后。特沃德罗斯说，你的女主人英国女王呢？天哪，她给我写回信了吗？卡梅伦说，很遗憾，我什么也没听到，我没有从伦敦收到任何消息。
But your majesty, I will give my head if I have two months, the answer to your letter is not here. And then Cameron vanishes again. And Teodros hears rumours that Cameron has gone back to the coast. And he's actually in Sudanese territory. He's talking to the Sudanese. Now, he is because the foreign office have been asking him to investigate the local slave trade, which they're keen to stamp out. But Teodros thinks this bloke, he didn't seem very comfortable anyway. He was always shifty. He hasn't brought me the answer to the letter, I wonder if he's gone out there to sell me out to the Muslims. I knew the British would sell me out. This is what he's thinking. So more months go by and all the time Teodros's
但是陛下，如果两个月内没有收到您信件的答复，我愿献上我的头颅。然后卡梅伦又消失了。特沃德罗斯听到传言说卡梅伦已经回到了海岸。他实际上是在苏丹领土上。他正在与苏丹人交谈。现在，他之所以在那里，是因为外交部一直要求他调查当地的奴隶贸易，他们急于根除这种贸易。但特沃德罗斯认为这个家伙，他看起来一点也不自在。他总是鬼鬼祟祟的。他没有给我带回信，我怀疑他是不是去那里把我出卖给穆斯林了。我就知道英国人会出卖我。他就是这么想的。于是又过了几个月，而特沃德罗斯的
paranoia is building. He cannot understand why Queen Victoria has not replied to his letter. At best, it shows she doesn't care about him. At worst, it's a sign that she is actually plotting with his Muslim enemies. And then in October, his impatience and distrust finally boil over and he completely loses it. And the man who provokes him is a missionary called Henry Aaron Stern, who was German-born in Hamburg, and he'd been sent to Abyssinia by a group called the London Society of Promoting Christianity Among the Jews. So they specialized in sending people to the Holy Land, to Ottoman-occupied Palestine, to try to convert people. And they'd started sending people to Abyssinia as well. And Stern has been in Abyssinia since 1860.
偏执情绪一直在增长。他不明白为什么维多利亚女王没有回复他的信。往好了说，这表明她不在乎他。往坏了说，这标志着她实际上正在与他的穆斯林敌人密谋。然后在十月，他的不耐烦和不信任终于爆发了，他彻底崩溃了。挑衅他的人是一位名叫亨利·亚伦·斯特恩的传教士，他出生于德国汉堡，被一个名为“伦敦促进犹太人基督教协会”的组织派往阿比西尼亚。他们专门派人去圣地，去奥斯曼帝国占领的巴勒斯坦，试图感化人们。他们也开始派人去阿比西尼亚。斯特恩自1860年以来一直待在阿比西尼亚。
he absolutely hated it. He's published a book called Wanderings Among the Flaashes, which is very caustic about Abyssinia. He said of the people of Abyssinia, they were a false, treacherous and insolent race, absurdly superstitious in their religious belief, and revoltingly obscene in their domestic relations. Can I ask, has he got an Abyssinian publishing deal?
他非常讨厌那里。他出版了一本名为《在法拉沙人中漫游》的书，书中对阿比西尼亚的评价非常尖刻。他谈到阿比西尼亚人民时说，他们是一个虚伪、背信弃义且傲慢的种族，在宗教信仰上荒谬地迷信，在家庭关系中令人作呕地淫秽。我可以问一下，他拿到阿比西尼亚的出版合同了吗？
No, this hasn't been translated into... I don't think it's been translated, but... somehow news of it has reached to Eudros. This guy hates you, hates your people, and has written disobliging things about you in the British press. Anyway, Stern doesn't like Abyssinia. He's planning to go home and he's on his way home when by an unbelievably unfortunate coincidence, he basically runs into Trojus's army and some of them have been drinking. There's an altercation with him and Stern ends up being arrested and beaten up and he's dragged to Teodros' tent.
不，这本书还没有被翻译成……我不认为它被翻译过，但是……不知何故，关于它的消息传到了特沃德罗斯耳中。这家伙恨你，恨你的人民，并且在英国媒体上写了关于你的不敬之词。总之，斯特恩不喜欢阿比西尼亚。他正计划回家，在回家的路上，极其不幸地，他基本上撞上了特沃德罗斯的军队，其中一些人喝了酒。他与他们发生了争执，斯特恩最终被逮捕并殴打，被拖到了特沃德罗斯的帐篷里。
And then he's thrown into a tent and manacled by his hands and his feet, and he lies there for weeks. And he's convinced that he is going to be killed. And basically the only thing that keeps him going is his Christian faith. And then five weeks later, Stern is dragged into this huge assembly of Teodros' troops. And the emperor is sitting there on his throne. And before the emperor's throne is Stern's closest colleague,
然后他被扔进一个帐篷，手脚被戴上镣铐，他在那里躺了几个星期。他确信自己会被杀掉。基本上，支撑他活下去的唯一动力就是他的基督教信仰。五周后，斯特恩被拖到了特沃德罗斯军队的一个大型集会上。皇帝正坐在他的宝座上。在皇帝的宝座前是斯特恩最亲密的同事，
who's another missionary called Henry Rosenthal and he is also in chains and Stur thinks, oh no. And a scribe reads out the charges against them. Stern is accused of mocking Teodros's counsellors of undermining Ethiopian Christianity of slandering the emperor as a war criminal and I quote, worst of all,
那是另一位名叫亨利·罗森塔尔的传教士，他也戴着镣铐，斯特恩心想，噢不。一名书记员宣读了对他们的指控。斯特恩被指控嘲笑特沃德罗斯的顾问，破坏埃塞俄比亚基督教，诽谤皇帝是战犯，我引用一下，最糟糕的是，
ridiculing the emperor's genealogy. He's definitely saying that he's the sender from Solomon, is he? He is, absolutely. Actually, there's a hilarious moment at this camp. they mention the genealogy thing, Teodros says to this guy, Stern, you doubt that I'm descended from Solomon. Here are the priests. They will recite my genealogy. And the priests start to recite the genealogy.
嘲笑皇帝的家谱。他肯定是在说他是所罗门的后裔，对吧？他确实是，绝对是。事实上，在这个营地里有一个滑稽的时刻。他们提到了家谱的事情，特沃德罗斯对这个家伙斯特恩说，你怀疑我是所罗门的后裔吗？祭司们都在这儿。他们会背诵我的家谱。于是祭司们开始背诵家谱。
And they do quite well at first. But apparently when they got to about the 15th or 16th century, they started to falter and to stutter. And then they started to argue among themselves. And Teodros went absolutely berserk and said, next time I tell you this, you will know. You will know my family tree. Anyway, so this is stern and then Rosenthal was accused of having written
起初他们做得还不错。但显然当他们背到大约15或16世纪时，他们开始结巴和口吃。然后他们开始互相争吵。特沃德罗斯彻底暴怒，说，下次我告诉你们时，你们就会知道了。你们会知道我的家谱的。总之，这就是斯特恩，然后罗森塔尔被指控写过
that the country would be better off under Egyptian rule and Teotros says to the two of them you Europeans came into this country and I loved honoured and respected you but you are liars and then they read the verdict they're sentenced to death
说这个国家在埃及统治下会更好，特沃德罗斯对他们两人说，你们欧洲人来到这个国家，我爱你们、尊重你们、敬重你们，但你们是骗子，然后他们宣读了判决，他们被判处死刑。
and they're dragged back to their tents but then nothing happens days passed and the sentence isn't carried out they're sometimes dragged out to the tents and forced to watch the sort of bloody execution of Abyssinian rebels and peasants, but the blade never falls on them. And in fact, their guards say to them after a few weeks, the emperor has relented, he's probably going to release you,
他们被拖回了帐篷，但什么也没发生，日子一天天过去，判决并没有执行，他们有时被拖出帐篷，被迫观看阿比西尼亚叛军和农民那种血腥的处决，但刀刃从未落在他们身上。事实上，几周后，他们的守卫对他们说，皇帝已经心软了，他可能会释放你们，
like he's going to forget all about it. And then on the 3rd January, 1864, they're brought before the emperor once again, and they're dragged before Teodros' throne, and they see to their relief around the throne, the British consul, Captain Cameron, and a load of other missionaries. And Stern thinks to himself, thank God for that. They've come and interceded for us, we are free at last.
就像他会把这一切都忘掉一样。然后在1864年1月3日，他们再次被带到皇帝面前，被拖到特沃德罗斯的宝座前，他们松了一口气，看到宝座周围有英国领事卡梅伦上尉和许多其他传教士。斯特恩心想，感谢上帝。他们来为我们求情了，我们终于自由了。
And then in his next thought, he notices the shackles on Cameron's legs. And one of the other missionaries looks at him and he whispers, we are all prisoners now. And that's the point when Stern realizes that their nightmare and this whole bonkers story are only just beginning. And we will find out what happens after a break. This episode is supported by Anthropic, the team behind Claude. Now history's biggest leaps, many of them started as hard questions that people didn't want asked.
然后在他接下来的想法中，他注意到了卡梅伦腿上的镣铐。其中一位传教士看着他，低声说，我们现在都是囚犯了。就在那一刻，斯特恩意识到他们的噩梦和整个疯狂的故事才刚刚开始。休息之后，我们将找出接下来发生了什么。本集由Claude背后的团队Anthropic赞助。现在，历史上最大的飞跃，其中许多始于人们不想被问到的难题。
Yeah, there's a classic example of that, Tom, at the end of the 15th century. And the hard question in particular was, what is out there beyond the Atlantic ocean to the west. And as you will know, the man who found the answer to that question was the explorer Christopher Columbus, great pioneering voyage of discovery, and it is, of course, the Americas. So, you know, Anthropic knows the importance of questions, and it's why Anthropic is founded on one hard question above all. How can we ensure that the AI revolution really goes well for ordinary people? Anthropic asked 100,000 people, and what came back wasn't just fear, there was hope as well. People wanted to know, will cancer ever be cured?
是的，汤姆，15世纪末有一个经典的例子。那个难题特别在于，大西洋西岸之外有什么。正如你所知，找到那个问题答案的人是探险家克里斯托弗·哥伦布，伟大的开创性发现之旅，当然，那就是美洲。所以，你知道，Anthropic知道问题的重要性，这就是为什么Anthropic建立在一个最重要的难题之上。我们如何确保人工智能革命对普通人来说真的进展顺利？Anthropic询问了10万人，得到的反馈不仅仅是恐惧，还有希望。人们想知道，癌症会被治愈吗？
Can kids have a better future? It turns out that there is hope in hard questions. Ask yours at clod.a.ai slash rest is history. And keep thinking. Hey, this is Michael and Hannah from Gollhangers, The Rest is Science. This episode is brought to you by Cancer Research UK. Think of some things that glow. Okay, fireflies, glow sticks, the northern lights.
孩子们能有更好的未来吗？事实证明，难题中蕴含着希望。在clod.a.ai slash rest is history上提出你的问题。并保持思考。嘿，这是来自Gollhangers的迈克尔和汉娜，《历史的其余部分》是科学。本集由英国癌症研究中心为您呈现。想想一些会发光的东西。好吧，萤火虫、荧光棒、北极光。
They're very cool. but what if we could replicate that glow inside our bodies and what if doing so could help us save lives? Because Cancer Research, UK scientists, they're investigating whether a special fluorescent dye that sticks to prostate cancer cells could tackle an ongoing challenge in the operating room, removing every single trace of cancer.
它们非常酷。但如果我们能复制体内的那种光芒，如果这样做能帮助我们拯救生命呢？因为英国癌症研究中心的科学家们正在研究一种能粘附在前列腺癌细胞上的特殊荧光染料，是否能解决手术室中一个持续存在的挑战，即清除癌症的每一丝痕迹。
Because when cancer cells are glowing and easy to spot, surgeons can precisely remove them, leaving healthy cells untouched, meaning there's less chance of the cancer, cancer returning and fewer nasty side effects. Cancer Research UK's vision is a world where everybody lives longer, better lives, free from the fear of cancer, with breakthroughs like this leading to kinder, more effective treatments. For more information about Cancer Research UK, their research and breakthroughs and how you can
因为当癌细胞发光且容易被发现时，外科医生可以精确地切除它们，让健康细胞不受影响，这意味着癌症复发的几率更小，副作用也更少。英国癌症研究中心的愿景是一个每个人都能活得更长、更好，免于癌症恐惧的世界，像这样的突破带来了更温和、更有效的治疗方法。有关英国癌症研究中心、他们的研究和突破以及您如何
support them, visit canterresearchuk.org slash rest is science. Don't you wish you could just hit skip on the worst parts of your life? You know, the same way you can skip an ad? I get it. I'm Siaia and I live in Ice Cove. I've made some questionable decisions that didn't end up the way I planned. And today, I'm still figuring it out. Somehow things usually get worse before they get better. Apparently, that's how I roll.
支持他们的更多信息，请访问canterresearchuk.org slash rest is science。你难道不想跳过生活中最糟糕的部分吗？你知道，就像你可以跳过广告一样？我明白。我是Siaia，我住在冰湾。我做了一些不明智的决定，结果并没有按我计划的那样发展。今天，我还在摸索。不知何故，事情通常在好转之前会变得更糟。显然，我就是这样。
So bundle up and come along for the bumpy ride. Stream a new episode of North of North Tuesdays on CBC Gem. Welcome back to the rest is history. It's May 1864 and we are in London, beating heart of us. a mighty empire, a city of railways and telegraphs and smoke, the crucible of modernity, absolutely tremendous days. And Dominic, in Whitehall, the Foreign Secretary, Lord Russell, is studying a scribbled pencil note which has been smuggled to the Red Sea coast and then carried by ship to London. And it reads, myself, Stern, Rosenthal, Keynes,
所以穿暖和点，一起来经历这段颠簸的旅程吧。在CBC Gem上观看每周二播出的《北之北》新剧集。欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。现在是1864年5月，我们在伦敦，一个强大帝国的跳动心脏，一个铁路、电报和烟雾的城市，现代性的熔炉，绝对了不起的日子。多米尼克，在白厅，外交大臣罗素勋爵正在研究一张潦草的铅笔便条，它被偷运到红海海岸，然后由船运往伦敦。上面写着，我自己、斯特恩、罗森塔尔、凯恩斯、
Bardell McCravey and McKilvie are all chained here. Flad, Stager, Brandes and Cornelius sent to Gaffat to work for the King. No release until civil answer to King's letter arrives and it signed CDC Charles Duncan Cameron. And Lord Russell, the Foreign Secretary, asked his officials, oh my God, are there any letters from the King of Abyssinia that we have neglected to answer? And what's the answer, Dominic? while they go digging into their files, and guess what? There is.
巴德尔、麦克雷维和麦基尔维都被锁在这里。弗拉德、斯塔格、布兰德斯和科尼利厄斯被派往加法特为国王工作。在国王的信得到文明答复之前，不会释放任何人，签名是CDC查尔斯·邓肯·卡梅伦。外交大臣罗素勋爵问他的官员，天哪，有什么阿比西尼亚国王的信是我们忽略了没有回复的吗？多米尼克，答案是什么？当他们去翻阅档案时，你猜怎么着？确实有。
This is Teodros' original letter that he had sent with Cameron. And what did it happen to this letter? It's an interesting story, actually, a revealing story. So it went across the Red Sea to Aden, and then went from Aden to Bombay, and then it went back across the Indian Ocean to Suez, and then it went across the desert to Alexandria, and by ship from Alexandria to Marseille, and then by train to the Channel Coast
这就是特沃德罗斯随卡梅伦寄出的那封原始信件。这封信发生了什么事？这其实是一个有趣的故事，一个发人深省的故事。它穿过红海到达亚丁，然后从亚丁到孟买，然后又穿过印度洋回到苏伊士，然后穿过沙漠到达亚历山大，从亚历山大乘船到马赛，然后乘火车到海峡海岸，
and then by boat across the coast and then by train to London. So the journey of this letter is a remarkable story. It tells you everything you need to know about the kind of globalised world of the British Empire. But when it finally got to the foreign office, the officials didn't know what to do with it. They just saw it as weird
然后乘船穿过海岸，再乘火车到伦敦。所以这封信的旅程是一个非凡的故事。它告诉你关于大英帝国那种全球化世界所需要知道的一切。但当它最终到达外交部时，官员们不知道该怎么处理它。他们只是觉得它很奇怪，
and a sort of distraction from bigger issues. And one of them wrote on Cameron's accompanying note, we can expect no advantage from meddling with the politics of Abyssinia. So the British actually do not want to intervene in Abyssinia. They're not interested in it. They forwarded the letter to the India office. It was filed away in the India office and people forgot all about it.
是比重大问题更让人分心的事情。其中一个人在卡梅伦的附信上写道，干涉阿比西尼亚的政治对我们没有任何好处。所以英国人实际上并不想干涉阿比西尼亚。他们对它不感兴趣。他们把信转交给了印度事务部。它被归档在印度事务部，人们把它忘得一干二净。
Anyway, now, 18 months on, they dig it out again. And they draft a reply from Queen Victoria, a reply which they hope, and I quote, will tempt the savage to let our people go. It's addressed to our good friend Teodros, king of Abyssinia. And Victoria, she says, I've heard that you've detained some of our people. And she says that Your Majesty
总之，现在，18个月过去了，他们又把它挖了出来。他们起草了一封维多利亚女王的回信，他们希望，我引用一下，这封信能诱使那个野蛮人放走我们的人。信是写给我们的好朋友阿比西尼亚国王特沃德罗斯的。维多利亚女王说，我听说你扣留了我们的一些人。她说，陛下
can give no better proof of the sincerity of the sentiments which you profess towards us than by dismissing our servant and any other Europeans who may desire it from your court and by affording them every assistance and protection on their journey. Is that your Queen Victoria voice?
除了遣散我们的仆人以及任何其他可能希望离开的欧洲人，并为他们的旅程提供一切协助和保护之外，没有更好的证据来证明您对我们所宣称的真诚情感。那是你的维多利亚女王声音吗？
That's the Queen Victoria's voice. Audio archive. And that signed Victoria R. Balmoral 26th of May 1864. And they say, well, obviously, we'll have to send somebody with this letter to persuade Tiodros to accept it as a sign of our friendship.
那是维多利亚女王的声音。音频档案。签名是维多利亚R. 巴尔莫勒尔，1864年5月26日。他们说，好吧，显然，我们必须派人带着这封信去说服特沃德罗斯接受它，作为我们友谊的象征。
And the reason they're doing this is not particularly that they're worried about the missionaries. I question how much they really care about the missionaries, to be brutally honest. What they really care about is, the French. Of course. So this is the point when Suez Canal mania is at its height. They are very anxious that if they alienate Tiodros, he will jump into bed with Paris. the French will end up controlling the Red Sea coast and that would mean the French would control the route between Suez and India
他们这样做并不是因为他们特别担心传教士。老实说，我怀疑他们到底有多在乎传教士。他们真正关心的是法国人。当然。所以这就是苏伊士运河狂热达到顶峰的时候。他们非常担心，如果他们疏远特沃德罗斯，他会和巴黎勾搭上。法国人最终会控制红海海岸，这意味着法国人将控制苏伊士和印度之间的路线，
and we cannot have that so they choose somebody to take this letter and to assure Teodros of Britain's friendship and the guy they choose is a really, really remarkable man called Homuzd Rassam and Tom you should like him on all kinds of levels Well he's born in Mosul wasn't he which is the home of Oma Mohammed
我们不能允许这种情况发生，所以他们选择了一个人带着这封信去向特沃德罗斯保证英国的友谊，他们选择的这个人是一个非常、非常了不起的人，名叫霍姆兹德·拉萨姆，汤姆，你应该在各个层面上都喜欢他。好吧，他出生在摩苏尔，不是吗？那是奥马·穆罕默德的家乡，
who did an extraordinary bonus for us a couple of weeks back. Yeah. And he's an ethnic Assyrian, Hormuz Rassam, and an archaeologist. I know you love a bit of archaeology. He did some digging at Nimrod and at Nineveh. Well, Nineveh is basically Mosul, so just right on his doorstep. And now I know as well, you love the British Museum. And this guy, Rassam, did a lot of work for the British Museum.
几周前他为我们做了一个非凡的特别节目。是的。他是一位亚述裔，霍姆兹·拉萨姆，也是一位考古学家。我知道你喜欢考古学。他在尼姆鲁德和尼尼微做了一些挖掘工作。嗯，尼尼微基本上就是摩苏尔，就在他家门口。现在我也知道，你喜欢大英博物馆。这个家伙，拉萨姆，为大英博物馆做了很多工作。
He discovered the palace of Ashurbanapal, which you will know far more about than I do. and he was instrumental in discovering the epic of Gilgamesh, the tablets. We must do an episode on that. Yeah, the epic of Gilgames would be brilliant. Anyway, so this guy, Rassam, there should be a statue of him at the British Museum. He was such a tremendous man. He travelled to England. He went to Mordland College, Oxford.
他发现了亚述巴尼拔的宫殿，你对此了解的肯定比我多。他在发现《吉尔伽美什史诗》泥板方面发挥了重要作用。我们必须做一期关于那个的节目。是的，吉尔伽美什史诗会很棒。总之，这个家伙，拉萨姆，大英博物馆应该为他立一座雕像。他是一个了不起的人。他去了英国。他去了牛津大学莫德林学院。
He converted to Protestantism when he was at Oxford. He became a massive Anglophile. He's a man who I reckon would wear a tweed suit to bed in the full. 40 degree heat of Ethiopia, unquestionably. And the foreign office had employed him as their political agent in Aden. You're right. He's a tremendous man. And Rassam is now in his mid-30s.
他在牛津时皈依了新教。他成了一个狂热的亲英派。我觉得他甚至会在埃塞俄比亚40度的高温下穿着粗花呢西装睡觉。毫无疑问。外交部聘请他担任他们在亚丁的政治代理人。你说得对。他是一个了不起的人。拉萨姆现在30多岁了。
Everyone says he's brilliant. Everyone says this guy is the absolute business. He's pleasant. He's polite. He's really good at archaeology. He knows loads about Assyria. He loves digging. He loves Britain.
每个人都说他很聪明。每个人都说这家伙绝对是个人才。他很讨人喜欢。他很有礼貌。他非常擅长考古。他了解很多关于亚述的知识。他喜欢挖掘。他热爱英国。
He's great. There's literally nothing to not to like. Exactly. The only person who doesn't like him actually is Sir Harry Flashman, who found him oily in Flashman and his memoir Flashman on the March. But every writer who's written about this says Rosam is fantastic. Good judgment, sensible, calm, level-headed, all of this. Rossam arrives on the Red Sea Coast at Masawa in July 1864 with two blokes, a doctor called Henry Blanc and Lieutenant Preeto of the Bombay Staff Corps. They've come as his assistance. Both with suspiciously French names. Well, here's the thing. There are some writers who say the British sent Rosam, Blanc, and Predo deliberately because if everything went wrong and they got into trouble, the British wouldn't care. So it would play well with the newspapers because they all had foreign names. That's the cunning, you see? That's the cunning of the British Foreign Office.
他很棒。真的没有什么可挑剔的。唯一不喜欢他的人其实是哈里·弗莱什曼爵士，他在《弗莱什曼》和他的回忆录《弗莱什曼在行军》中觉得他油嘴滑舌。但每一位写过这件事的作家都说拉萨姆很棒。判断力好，明智，冷静，头脑清醒，所有这些。拉萨姆于1864年7月抵达红海海岸的马萨瓦，带着两个人，一位名叫亨利·布兰克的医生和孟买参谋部的普里托中尉。他们是作为他的助手来的。两人都有着令人怀疑的法国名字。嗯，事情是这样的。有些作家说英国人故意派拉萨姆、布兰克和普里托去，因为如果一切出错，他们陷入麻烦，英国人也不会在乎。所以这在报纸上会很受欢迎，因为他们都有外国名字。这就是狡猾之处，你明白吗？这就是英国外交部的狡猾。
That is the animal cunning with the British Foreign Office that has slightly gone missing recently. Definitely. We used to be a real country. So anyway, Rassam sends a letter inland. Teodros and he waits and two months go by and all the time he's trying to get intel on the guy he's got to do business with. So one, Teodros's reputation now is very bad. One trader says to him, he is the scourge of humanity, the arch enemy of humankind. But the local ruler on the Red Sea Coast says, no, that's not true at all. He says he's actually a very kind man. He's just been led
这就是英国外交部那种最近稍微消失了的动物般的狡猾。绝对是。我们曾经是一个真正的国家。所以总之，拉萨姆寄了一封信到内陆。特沃德罗斯，他等待着，两个月过去了，他一直在试图获取他必须打交道的那个人情报。所以，特沃德罗斯现在的名声很差。一位商人对他说，他是人类的祸害，人类的死敌。但红海海岸的当地统治者说，不，那根本不是真的。他说他实际上是一个非常善良的人。他只是被
astray by the natural bloodlust of the Abyssinian people. And then the local ruler adds the ominous remark, of course he's also insane. So they keep waiting. It's incredibly hot. So they have to camp outside in what was once Plowden's garden. There's cholera, there's a famine. It's all terrible. They're waiting for news. And finally, letters arrive not from Teotras, but from the hostages themselves. So these are Stern, Rosenthal, Cameron and the other missionaries. Now, a lot of time has passed. They have been in captivity now for 18 months. And their conditions are so. sub-ideal. They've been kept chained up initially in the royal camp. They didn't see much of Teodros. Occasionally, when he'd been drinking, he would come into the tents where they were
阿比西尼亚人民天生的嗜血本性误导了。然后当地统治者补充了一个不祥的评论，当然他也疯了。所以他们一直在等。天气热得难以置信。所以他们不得不露宿在曾经是普劳登花园的地方。那里有霍乱，有饥荒。一切都很糟糕。他们在等消息。终于，信件到了，不是来自特沃德罗斯，而是来自人质本人。所以这些是斯特恩、罗森塔尔、卡梅伦和其他传教士。现在，已经过去很长时间了。他们现在已经被囚禁了18个月。他们的条件非常。不理想。他们最初被锁在皇家营地里。他们没怎么见到特沃德罗斯。偶尔，当他喝醉时，他会走进他们被
chained up in a massive rage. He would have them bound in very tight cords, sort of like ropes, and then he would have them doused in cold water, which seems a bit mean. Well, I don't know. It depends how hot it is. Yeah, you'd probably steam, would you? It's really hot. He might steam. No one was that. No one was that. It's hot. You like a cold shower. He has a massive hatred of this guy stern, a passionate hatred of the guy who had mocked his genealogy. He said, give me the name of the man who were reviled my ancestors or I will rip it from your heart. He's obsessed with the idea that they have kind of local collaborators. The time goes by, their clothes are rags, they're living on a sort of handful of dried peas.
锁住的帐篷里，大发雷霆。他会让他们被非常紧的绳子捆住，就像绳索一样，然后他会让他们被冷水浇透，这看起来有点刻薄。嗯，我不知道。这取决于天气有多热。是的，你可能会冒蒸汽，对吧？真的很热。他可能会冒蒸汽。没人那样。没人那样。很热。你喜欢冷水澡。他对这个家伙斯特恩有着巨大的仇恨，对那个嘲笑他家谱的家伙有着强烈的仇恨。他说，告诉我那个侮辱我祖先的人的名字，否则我就把它从你的心里挖出来。他沉迷于他们有当地合作者的想法。时间流逝，他们的衣服成了破布，他们靠一把干豌豆生活。
It rains in the summer. They're very sodden, they're miserable, they're very ill. and at the end of 1864 they are dragged out of their tents to join this long column of Teodros's prisoners so these are captured rebels disgraced officials, common criminals
夏天会下雨。他们非常湿透，他们很痛苦，他们病得很重。1864年底，他们被拖出帐篷，加入了特沃德罗斯的长长囚犯队伍，所以这些是被俘的叛军、丢官的官员、普通罪犯。
they're marched out across the highlands for seven days and after a week they're absolutely exhausted and then finally they see ahead at their destination the towering cliffs of Magdalar which is Teodros' mountain citadel and this is his favourite head-caulted.
他们被带出高地行进了七天，一周后他们精疲力竭，然后终于在前方看到了他们的目的地，马格达拉高耸的悬崖，这是特沃德罗斯的山中堡垒。这是他最喜欢的堡垒。
The writer Philip Marston, who wrote a brilliant book about this called The Barefoot Emperor, which I recommend to the listeners. He calls Magdala his garrison, his prison, his stronghold and home, his asylum, his treasury, and his dungeon. This is the helms deep of Abyssinia, this mountain fastness. If you go up to the top, you look out, you can see miles and miles around, people approaching. Even a small force can hold this mountain indefinitely. And in the walled compound on the top of the mountain, Teodros keeps his most valuable treasures. And these are things he's looted from churches across Abyssinia. Oh, okay.
作家菲利普·马斯顿写了一本关于这件事的精彩书籍，叫《赤脚皇帝》，我向听众推荐。他称马格达拉为他的驻军、他的监狱、他的据点和家、他的避难所、他的金库和他的地牢。这是阿比西尼亚的圣盔谷，这个山中要塞。如果你走到顶端，向外看，你可以看到方圆数英里，人们在靠近。即使是一小支部队也可以无限期地守住这座山。在山顶的围墙大院里，特沃德罗斯存放着他从阿比西尼亚各地的教堂里掠夺来的最珍贵的宝藏。哦，好吧。
So the British aren't the only people who've done some looting in this story. Oh, good. No, no, not at all. This is the stuff that will end up in Toronto. And he also keeps his most important prisoners. So his rivals, pretenders, the heirs to various regional kingdoms and things. Now it keeps the European prisoners separately. They're in huts by the cliff edge, just 20 yards from the cliff edge,
所以英国人并不是这个故事中唯一进行掠夺的人。哦，太好了。不，不，一点也不。这些东西最终会进入多伦多。他还关押着他最重要的囚犯。所以他的竞争对手、觊觎者、各个地区王国的继承人等等。现在他把欧洲囚犯分开关押。他们在悬崖边的棚屋里，距离悬崖边只有20码，
which some of them find disturbingly close. The huts are infested with spiders and rats. The hostages, the missionaries, are fettered at the ankles, and then these fetters are connected by a chain to a manacle on their hands, but the chain that is a little bit too short. So they're hunched over the whole time, and if they want to move around, they're still hunched. and they develop severe spinal pain, which is not good.
其中一些人觉得距离近得令人不安。棚屋里到处是蜘蛛和老鼠。人质、传教士的脚踝被戴上镣铐，然后这些镣铐通过一条链子连接到他们手上的手铐上，但链子太短了。所以他们一直弯着腰，如果他们想四处走动，他们仍然是弯着腰的。他们患上了严重的脊椎疼痛，这可不好。
But from here, Cameron has smuggled messages to the coast. And as Rassam on the coast reads these messages, he's quite disturbed. Because Cameron says, I'm convinced that only military action will persuade the emperor to release us. And he adds a note to Rassam. He says, for God's sake, do not come up here. He will cage you as sure as a gun. And this leaves Rassam in a bit of a quandary.
但从这里，卡梅伦偷运了信息到海岸。当拉萨姆在海岸读到这些信息时，他感到非常不安。因为卡梅伦说，我确信只有军事行动才能说服皇帝释放我们。他给拉萨姆加了一张便条。他说，看在上帝的份上，不要到这里来。他会像关枪一样把你关起来。这让拉萨姆陷入了困境。
Do I not go? Am I ever going to get a letter from the emperor himself? What shall I do? And then in August, 1865, the emperor's reply finally arrives. And it's a litany of grievances against Stern and Cameron in particular. But also implicitly, they're not quite explicitly stated. There's an invitation to Rassam. Why don't you come and talk to me?
我不去吗？我还能收到皇帝本人的信吗？我该怎么办？然后在1865年8月，皇帝的回复终于到了。这是一份针对斯特恩和卡梅伦的怨言清单。但也隐含地，虽然没有完全明确说明。有一个对拉萨姆的邀请。你为什么不来和我谈谈呢？
So Rassam gets permission from London. And then he heads inland with his assistants Dr. Blanc and Lieutenant Predo. The countryside by now is barren, desolate, scarred by war and rebellion and famine and plague. The people are kind of skeletal and ghostly, kind of, you know, it's like something from a zombie apocalypse or something. And all the time as they advance, it's very kind of Cortezan Montezuma or something. Because all the time, Rassam is getting these rambling letters from Teodros that lurched, from a kind of aggressive self-pity to, you know, polite, friendly apologies.
所以拉萨姆得到了伦敦的许可。然后他带着他的助手布兰克医生和普里托中尉前往内陆。此时的乡村荒凉、凄凉，被战争、叛乱、饥荒和瘟疫所破坏。人们看起来像骷髅和鬼魂，你知道，就像僵尸启示录之类的东西。在他们前进的过程中，这非常像科尔特斯和蒙特祖玛之类的东西。因为拉萨姆一直在收到特沃德罗斯那些漫无边际的信件，从一种咄咄逼人的自怜到，你知道，礼貌、友好的道歉。
So Sam doesn't really know what to make of this. Anyway, the 28th of January 1866, they reached George Ross's camp. And Rasam has been waiting for this moment for a year and a half. I mean, this is a very long-winded enterprise. And he gets into his finery, his best blue diplomatic uniform, and Blanc and Preeto are wearing the red uniforms of the British... Indian Army. And once again, you'll be pleased to hear that they find Teodros reclining on a divan surrounded by musicians and courtiers and bodyguards. And Rosam hands over Queen Victoria's letter.
所以萨姆真的不知道该怎么处理这个。总之，1866年1月28日，他们到达了乔治·罗斯的营地。拉萨姆已经为这一刻等待了一年半。我的意思是，这是一个非常冗长的企业。他穿上了他的盛装，他最好的蓝色外交制服，布兰克和普里托穿着英国……印度军队的红色制服。再一次，你会很高兴听到他们发现特沃德罗斯躺在沙发上，周围环绕着音乐家、朝臣和保镖。拉萨姆交出了维多利亚女王的信。
And Teodros goes into a huge rant about his grievances, not just against the missionaries, but against his own people. He says, my own people are useless as well. They're rebellious and violent and uncivilised. I don't know what to do. I'm beset by opponents. No one understands me, all this. And Rassam plays all this very skillfully. He doesn't argue with Teodros. He says, oh, I really do sympathise with you. You have a terrible job.
特沃德罗斯对他的不满进行了一番长篇大论，不仅是对传教士，也是对他自己的人民。他说，我的人民也毫无用处。他们叛逆、暴力且不文明。我不知道该怎么办。我被对手包围了。没有人理解我，所有这些。拉萨姆非常巧妙地处理了这一切。他没有与特沃德罗斯争论。他说，哦，我真的很同情你。你有一份可怕的工作。
You know, I wouldn't want to be in your shoes. You're the father of your people. Maybe the thing to do is to cultivate patience and tolerance. And maybe you can teach your people to do what is right. Anyway, I've got a letter here from Green Victoria. I'm confident that when you read the letter, you will forget the past and try to establish amicable relations with England. And when Teodros hears this, he is delighted.
你知道，我不想站在你的立场上。你是你人民的父亲。也许该做的是培养耐心和宽容。也许你可以教你的人民做正确的事。总之，我这里有一封来自维多利亚女王的信。我相信当你读到这封信时，你会忘记过去，并试图与英国建立友好的关系。当特沃德罗斯听到这个时，他很高兴。
He is absolutely, he's really touched. In fact, he's so touched that that night he can't sleep, he's so excited. He's finally got the reply that he wanted from Queen Victoria. And the next day he adorn, he dictates a new letter to Victoria. He says, I know God has chosen you from all men to be the champion of religion, to be the friend of the poor and the oppressed. He says to her, You must have heard of the ignorance and blindness of us,
他绝对，他真的很感动。事实上，他太感动了，那天晚上他睡不着觉，他太兴奋了。他终于收到了他想要的来自维多利亚女王的回复。第二天，他口述了一封给维多利亚的新信。他说，我知道上帝从所有人中选择了你作为宗教的捍卫者，作为穷人和受压迫者的朋友。他对她说，你一定听说过我们的无知和盲目，
the Ethiopian people. If you find offensive what I was bold enough to write to you, do not be angry with me. Advise me, for you, the queen whom God has chosen, have had your eyes opened. I mean, who knows what Queen Victoria would make of this. Anyway, he summons Rosam to his tent, and he says, you know, I'm feeling so happy.
埃塞俄比亚人民。如果你觉得我大胆写给你的东西冒犯了你，请不要对我生气。给我建议，因为你，上帝选择的女王，已经睁开了眼睛。我的意思是，谁知道维多利亚女王会怎么看待这个。总之，他召见拉萨姆到他的帐篷，他说，你知道，我感到非常高兴。
Now, I'm going to really. least all the captives. I'm going to bring them down from, they're on the top of the mountain. I'm going to bring them down from the mountain at Magdalya, and you can take them to the coast. You can have free passage. And Rassam, this is a massive result for Rassam. He is totally vindicated the foreign officer's faith. And Tiodros says there is one catch. It's going to take quite a long time to bring the hostages down from Magdala. And in the meantime, I've got some rebels to deal with. I'd love it if you would come with me. And Rassam says, yeah, fine. So they ride out at the head of thousands of men.
现在，我真的要释放所有的俘虏。我要把他们从山上带下来，他们在山顶上。我要把他们从马格达拉的山上带下来，你可以带他们去海岸。你可以自由通行。对于拉萨姆来说，这是一个巨大的成果。他完全证明了外交部的信念。特沃德罗斯说有一个陷阱。把人质从马格达拉带下来需要很长时间。与此同时，我还有一些叛军要处理。如果你能和我一起去，我会很高兴的。拉萨姆说，好的，没问题。所以他们骑马走在数千人的前面。
And during the march, again, it's very Montezuma and Cortez or something. Teotros often says, I'd like that guy to ride with me, please. And he questions him about the British Empire, how are you getting on in West Africa against the Ashanti? All this kind of thing. It keeps pestering him with questions about the Crimean War. He cannot get his head around the fact that the British won the Crimean War, but then signed a treaty with Tsar Nicholas I first and didn't execute.
在行军过程中，这又非常像蒙特祖玛和科尔特斯之类的东西。特沃德罗斯经常说，我希望那个家伙和我一起骑马，请。他问他关于大英帝国的问题，你们在西非对抗阿散蒂人进展如何？所有这些事情。他不断地用关于克里米亚战争的问题纠缠他。他无法理解英国赢得了克里米亚战争，但随后与沙皇尼古拉一世签署了条约，并没有处决他。
you, Tim. That blows his mind. So there's that. But then there's two themes that he keeps coming back to. He's like, mind will wander and then he'll come back to these themes. One of them is how the missionaries were very rude to him and rude about his genealogy. And whenever he talks about, he starts shaking because he's so cross. And then the other thing, he says, actually, I would like a formal treaty with the British show are, of course, my brothers.
你，蒂姆。这让他大吃一惊。所以有那个。但随后有两个主题他不断回到。他就像，思想会游离，然后他会回到这些主题。其中之一是传教士对他非常粗鲁，对他的家谱非常粗鲁。每当他谈到这个，他就开始颤抖，因为他太生气了。然后另一件事，他说，实际上，我想要一个与英国的正式条约，当然，他们是我的兄弟。
And I would love it. He says, I know Queen Victoria is two. I know she's very important and very busy and she's, you know, I'm small fry to her. But I also know she has a lot of governors in India and I would love it if she would appoint one of her governors in India to be my sort of contact, my point man, just for me, that I could talk to. And Rassam is very diplomatic, you know. He says to him, well, when I get back to London with the hostages, I will talk to her magistrate's government and I'm sure they'll look kindly on your majesty's proposal.
我很乐意。他说，我知道维多利亚女王是二。我知道她非常重要，非常忙，她是，你知道，我对她来说是小人物。但我也知道她在印度有很多总督，如果她能任命她的一位印度总督作为我的联系人，我的联络人，只为我，我可以和他交谈，我会很高兴的。拉萨姆非常外交，你知道。他对他说，好吧，当我带着人质回到伦敦时，我会和她的政府谈谈，我相信他们会善待陛下的提议。
Teodros says, oh, great, thank you. they reach a place called Lake Tana. Here they part. Tiodros is going off to attack some rebels and Rassam's going to wait for the hostages. And Rassam waits by the lakeside for the hostages and every few days Tiodros sends him gifts on letters. So Tiodros sends him some bizarre gifts.
特沃德罗斯说，哦，太好了，谢谢。他们到达了一个叫塔纳湖的地方。在这里他们分开了。特沃德罗斯要去攻击一些叛军，拉萨姆要等待人质。拉萨姆在湖边等待人质，每隔几天特沃德罗斯就会送他礼物和信件。所以特沃德罗斯送给他一些奇怪的礼物。
He sends him muskets, pistols, manuscripts that he's looted. He sends Rassam an antelope, two lion cubs, two monkeys and a baboon. Oh, really? Yeah. He could start his own zoo with this stuff. is a menagerie. What does Rassam do with them?
他送给他火枪、手枪、他掠夺的手稿。他送给拉萨姆一只羚羊、两只幼狮、两只猴子和一只狒狒。哦，真的吗？是的。他可以用这些东西开自己的动物园。是一个动物园。拉萨姆用它们做什么？
Didn't they just hang out? Just hang out, the baboon and the antelope and the lion cubs? I mean, they're well known for getting on with one another. What could go wrong? And also a load of irreplaceable ancient manuscripts. If ever I'm given an ancient manuscript, I make sure to put it with a baboon, because I think what could go wrong? Anyway, on the 12th of March, 1866, the hostages finally turn up. They've been marched down through the mountains. They're absolutely knackered. They're ill. There's 23 of them. They're not still,
他们不是就在那儿待着吗？就在那儿待着，狒狒、羚羊和幼狮？我的意思是，它们以相处融洽而闻名。能出什么错？还有一堆不可替代的古代手稿。如果我被赠予一份古代手稿，我一定会确保把它和狒狒放在一起，因为我想能出什么错？总之，1866年3月12日，人质终于出现了。他们被带下山。他们精疲力竭。他们病了。有23个人。他们不是仍然，
they haven't got this kind of, they're fettered to the ankles with their curved spire. They have been fettered all the way. How do they walk? It's just general trudging, I think. Sort of hunched over trudging.
他们没有那种，他们被脚镣锁着，脊椎弯曲。他们一路都被锁着。他们怎么走路？我想只是普通的跋涉。那种弯着腰的跋涉。
Oh, that's awful. They're alive. I mean, that's a plus. Their chains, because their chains are not removed until they get to the lake. And at that point,
哦，那太可怕了。他们还活着。我的意思是，这是一个加分项。他们的锁链，因为他们的锁链直到他们到达湖边才被取下。在那一点上，
Rassam thinks, finally, you know, this is, we've sorteded this out. Teotros, who at this stage appears absolutely lovesick.
拉萨姆心想，终于，你知道，这是，我们已经解决了这个问题。特沃德罗斯，在这个阶段看起来绝对是相思病。
He's so infatuated with Rassam. He's still sending him presents. He sends him some cows. He sends him some money. He says, please don't go off just yet. I'm having a special medal made for you. It's called the Cross and Solomon Seal. I've also commissioned special shields for you and Dr. Blanc and Lieutenant Predo
他非常迷恋拉萨姆。他还在给他送礼物。他送给他一些牛。他送给他一些钱。他说，请不要这么快离开。我正在为你制作一枚特别的奖章。它叫十字架和所罗门印章。我还为你、布兰克医生和普里托中尉订制了特别的盾牌，
and a special golden saddle for you to mark our friendship. In all, Teotros sent Rassam 23 letters. And Rassam at this point starts to finish. a little, he knows you might, a little disturbed, this friendship has got an unhealthy dimension to it. Because basically it appears that Tiodros has got a massive crush on him, a pash. And yeah, a pash. And Rassam becomes genuinely concerned. Is he ever going to, is he going to let me go? Because he seems absolutely besotted with me. And at last, Ciodros arrives back at the lake. And his first words to Rassam, perhaps a little bit ominous
还有一副特别的金色马鞍给你，以纪念我们的友谊。总共，特沃德罗斯给拉萨姆寄了23封信。拉萨姆在这一点上开始有点，他知道你可能，有点不安，这种友谊有一种不健康的维度。因为基本上看起来特沃德罗斯对他有巨大的迷恋，一种激情。是的，一种激情。拉萨姆变得真正担心起来。他会，他会让我走吗？因为他似乎完全被我迷住了。终于，特沃德罗斯回到了湖边。他对拉萨姆的第一句话，也许有点不祥，
because he takes him by the hand and says to him, I feel as happy as if I were visiting the queen. So that says, oh, brilliant. And then Teodros says, I want to introduce you to my eldest son. Can you shake hands, please? And he says, I would really love it if Queen Victoria would adopt my sons as her wards. So that when I die, they may be looked after by the English and not allowed to govern badly. And Rassam says, yeah, we can probably look into that.
因为他拉着他的手对他说，我感到非常高兴，就像我在拜访女王一样。所以这说，哦，太棒了。然后特沃德罗斯说，我想把你介绍给我长子。你能握个手吗？他说，如果维多利亚女王能收养我的儿子作为她的受监护人，我会很高兴的。这样当我死后，他们可以由英国人照顾，而不是被允许治理得不好。拉萨姆说，是的，我们可能可以研究一下。
Fine. Now, Tiodros at this point is very erratic. I think there's probably a lot of drinking. He's still lurching between these attacks on the missionaries and then he'll burst into tears and say how much he loves Britain and how he loves Rassam and Queen Victoria. At one point, he gets very mordland. He says to Rassam, I know that when you go you will forget me.
好的。现在，特沃德罗斯在这一点上非常不稳定。我想可能有很多喝酒。他仍然在这些对传教士的攻击之间摇摆，然后他会突然哭起来，说他有多爱英国，他有多爱拉萨姆和维多利亚女王。有一次，他变得非常忧郁。他对拉萨姆说，我知道当你走的时候你会忘记我。
You will forget your friend and all this. I mean, to be fair to Rassam, Rassam is not going to forget this, is he? No. This bloke has given you a baboon and burst into tears. front of you, you're never going to forget it. You don't forget a man who gives you a baboon. I remember all the people who've given me baboons. So Rassam is a little bit anxious but on the 13th of April
你会忘记你的朋友和所有这些。我的意思是，对拉萨姆公平地说，拉萨姆不会忘记这个，对吧？不。这家伙给了你一只狒狒，并在你面前突然哭了起来，你永远不会忘记它。你不会忘记一个给你狒狒的人。我记得所有给我狒狒的人。所以拉萨姆有点焦虑，但在4月13日，
orders come that the camp is going to be packed up and he thinks at last, you know, we are going to go home. The missionaries wait on the eastern side of the lake. Rassam and Dr Blanc and Lieutenant Predo cross the lake to go and say goodbye to Tiodros. It's only polite to say goodbye to him. And they get to his camp and they find it oddly sight.
命令下来了，营地要收拾行李，他心想终于，你知道，我们要回家了。传教士在湖的东侧等待。拉萨姆、布兰克医生和普里托中尉穿过湖去和特沃德罗斯告别。向他告别只是礼貌。他们到达了他的营地，发现它奇怪地安静。
and they are shown by the guards into Teodros's pavilion. And in his pavilion are all Teodros's courtiers and his bodyguards, as usual, who are just staring at them. But the throne is at the end of the pavilion, and there's no Teodros on the throne, which they find weird. And at that moment, they notice there's no one on the throne, where Sam feels a hand on his arm, and then he feels a hand on his other arm,
他们被卫兵带进了特沃德罗斯的凉亭。凉亭里像往常一样坐满了特沃德罗斯的朝臣和保镖，他们只是盯着他们看。但凉亭尽头是王座，王座上却没有特沃德罗斯，这让他们觉得很奇怪。就在那一刻，他们注意到王座上空无一人，萨姆感到一只手搭在他的手臂上，接着他又感到另一只手搭在他另一条手臂上，
and it's the guards. and he realizes they're under arrest. No. Yes, that's the twist. Oh my God. Yeah. I believed in Teodros' love for him. I think Teodros does love Rassam.
是卫兵。他意识到他们被捕了。不。是的，这就是反转。天哪。是的。我曾相信特沃德罗斯对他的爱。我想特沃德罗斯确实爱拉萨姆。
So the missionaries, by the way, are being rounded up at this point again. Again. Oh, and put back in their shackles. I put back in their shackles. Now, let's come to this. What's going on? What is Teodros thinking? There were various possibilities.
顺便说一下，传教士们此时又被抓了起来。又一次。哦，又被戴上了镣铐。我被戴上了镣铐。现在，让我们谈谈这个。发生了什么事？特沃德罗斯在想什么？有几种可能性。
Number one is that he was lying all the time. He was playing games with Rassam. Number two is that he wasn't, but at the last minute, he was overcome by his hatred of the missionaries. And number three is he loved, he did love Rassam after all. Yeah, he couldn't bear to let him go. Couldn't bear to let him go. I think that seems to the likeliest. Well, in his biography of Tiodros and his sort of discussion of this, Philip Marsden says,
第一，他一直都在撒谎。他在和拉萨姆玩游戏。第二，他没有撒谎，但在最后一刻，他被对传教士的仇恨冲昏了头脑。第三，他爱拉萨姆，毕竟他确实爱拉萨姆。是的，他舍不得让他走。舍不得让他走。我认为这似乎是最有可能的。嗯，菲利普·马斯登在关于特沃德罗斯的传记和对这件事的讨论中说，
you know, Rassam couldn't really understand it. And like Rassam, we are lost in a labyrinth of contradictory messages made more confusing by the emperor's growing paranoia. However, Marsden says, probably Teodros is infatuated with Rassam and he sees Rassam as his best chance of getting friendship with Britain and getting British technology and there's a sort of link with the outside world and he simply cannot bear to let him go. He wants to keep him. In a way, quite touching. Yeah, in a weird way, it is actually quite touching. I mean, not for Rassam, obviously, but... No. Anyway, so three days later, the whole load of them, brought into his tent for yet another show trial.
你知道，拉萨姆真的无法理解。就像拉萨姆一样，我们迷失在矛盾信息的迷宫中，而皇帝日益增长的偏执让这一切变得更加混乱。然而，马斯登说，特沃德罗斯可能迷恋拉萨姆，他把拉萨姆视为与英国建立友谊、获得英国技术的最佳机会，这是一种与外部世界的联系，他根本舍不得让他走。他想留住他。从某种程度上说，这相当感人。是的，从某种奇怪的角度来看，这确实相当感人。我的意思是，对拉萨姆来说显然不是，但是……不。总之，三天后，他们所有人被带到他的帐篷里，又进行了一场表演性审判。
So it's now quite correct. There's about 30 of them. So Rassam and Predo and Blonk and whatnot. Yeah, he's collecting quite a lot, isn't he? Yeah, Tiodros is collecting hostages. The full set. And Teodros says, this is all your fault, Rassam. You should have brought the missionaries to see me before you left.
现在大概有30个人。所以拉萨姆、普雷多、布隆克之类的。是的，他收集的人还真不少，不是吗？是的，特沃德罗斯正在收集人质。全套。特沃德罗斯说，这都是你的错，拉萨姆。你在离开之前应该带传教士来见我。
It was very rude of you not to bring them when you came to say goodbye. Is this your friendship, Mr. Rassam, that you wish to leave me and take away those who have abused me? and the next day, Theodorus dictates a new letter to Queen Victoria. He says, I'm actually keeping your envoy and all these people as my guests. And in the meantime, I would like you to send me some skillful artists to make me some guns. Oh, they're always the gunsmiths. I want blacksmiths, I want gunsmiths, I want artillery specialists.
你来告别时没带他们，这太无礼了。拉萨姆先生，这就是你的友谊吗？你想离开我，还要带走那些虐待我的人？第二天，特沃德罗斯口述了一封给维多利亚女王的新信。他说，我实际上是把你的特使和这些人当作我的客人留下了。同时，我希望你派一些熟练的艺术家来为我制造枪支。哦，总是枪匠。我想要铁匠，我想要枪匠，我想要炮兵专家。
And when I'm satisfied, I shall, through the power of God, give them a splendid payment and with great honour, send them back. Now, he's got to get this letter to Queen Victoria. And of course he doesn't want to let Rassam go. So he chooses one of the missionaries to do it. And this is a German man with the terrible name of Martin Flad. And he's a reverend. The Reverend Martin Flad had also been sent by the London Society for the promotion of Christianity among the Jews.
当我满意时，我将借上帝的力量，给予他们丰厚的报酬，并以极大的荣誉送他们回去。现在，他必须把这封信送到维多利亚女王手中。当然，他不想放走拉萨姆。所以他选择了其中一名传教士去送信。这是一个德国人，名字很可怕，叫马丁·弗拉德。他是一位牧师。马丁·弗拉德牧师也是由伦敦促进犹太人基督教化协会派来的。
And Flad had come to Abyssinia with his wife and three children. Flad doesn't want to leave his family behind. He hates Tiodrosi calls him a savage, a cruel inhuman and sly despot. But he feels he doesn't have any choice. So Flad sets off with this letter. He makes very good progress. He gets to London in July 1866.
弗拉德带着妻子和三个孩子来到阿比西尼亚。弗拉德不想把家人留在身后。他讨厌特沃德罗斯，称他为野蛮人、残忍、不人道且狡猾的暴君。但他觉得他别无选择。于是弗拉德带着这封信出发了。他进展非常顺利。他于1866年7月到达伦敦。
And he goes to the foreign office, and he gives them the letter, and he tells them Tiodros' demands. And he says to them, this bloke Tiodros is mad. Don't send troops. If British soldiers set foot on Abyssinian soil, he will in a most cruel and barbarous manner
他去了外交部，把信交给了他们，并告诉了他们特沃德罗斯的要求。他对他们说，这个叫特沃德罗斯的家伙疯了。不要派军队。如果英国士兵踏上阿比西尼亚的土地，他将以最残忍和野蛮的方式
slaughter out all our people. Just give him what he wants. You know, we've done hostage crises before. We did the Iran hostage crisis. This is a problem, you know, that is a perennial issue that governments have to face. Do you intervene militarily? Or does that mean you risk the deaths of all the hostages? Anyway, the foreign office at this point think, well, we don't want to intervene in Abyssinia.
屠杀我们所有的人。只要给他他想要的就行。你知道，我们以前处理过人质危机。我们处理过伊朗人质危机。你知道，这是一个政府必须面对的长期问题。你是进行军事干预吗？还是说这意味着你要冒着所有人质死亡的风险？总之，外交部此时认为，好吧，我们不想干预阿比西尼亚。
They arrange for loads of stuff, a mad collection of stuff, a steam engine and gunpowder mill, smelting equipment, a hunting rifle, a telescope. This is all going to be sent to the Red Sea and they're going to send a team of workmen to handle it. However, there is a catch. They say to Flad, you go ahead with a new letter from Queen Victoria. And when Teodros releases the hostages, he can have his smelting equipment, not before.
他们安排了大量的东西，一大堆疯狂的东西，蒸汽机和火药磨坊、冶炼设备、猎枪、望远镜。这些都要送到红海，他们还要派一队工人去处理。然而，有一个陷阱。他们对弗拉德说，你带着维多利亚女王的一封新信继续前进。当特沃德罗斯释放人质时，他才能得到他的冶炼设备，在此之前不行。
So, Flad goes back to Abyssinia. He gets to the Red Sea coast. There are messages from the hostages waiting for him, including his wife and children. They're all alive, but they're having a very, very weird time as guests of the emperor. So on the one hand, Teodros has presented Rassam with his medal and his golden saddle. He threw a party for Queen Victoria's birthday.
于是，弗拉德回到了阿比西尼亚。他到达了红海海岸。那里有来自人质的消息在等他，包括他的妻子和孩子。他们都还活着，但作为皇帝的客人，他们过得非常非常奇怪。一方面，特沃德罗斯向拉萨姆赠送了他的奖章和金马鞍。他为维多利亚女王的生日举办了派对。
He demonstrated some of his guns. He's taken Rassam shooting. And they have had some excellent chats about Alexander the Great. Because Teodros is, did you know this? Teodros is not just descended from Solomon. he's actually also descended from Alexander. I did not know that. Goodness.
他展示了一些他的枪支。他带拉萨姆去打猎。他们还就亚历山大大帝进行了一些精彩的交谈。因为特沃德罗斯是，你知道吗？特沃德罗斯不仅是所罗门的后裔，他实际上也是亚历山大的后裔。我不知道这一点。天哪。
So more complexity for his genealogists to wrestle with. Exactly. There's a lot going on there. On the other hand, occasionally Teodros will go mad. He will force them to watch him whipping his courtiers to death. And he will go into these mad rants and things. And do we think these stories are true? Because mad despots having rants and whipping people to death is a kind of staple of...
所以他的家谱学家要处理更多复杂的问题。没错。那里发生了很多事情。另一方面，特沃德罗斯偶尔会发疯。他会强迫他们看着他把朝臣鞭打致死。他会陷入这种疯狂的咆哮等等。我们认为这些故事是真的吗？因为疯狂的暴君咆哮和鞭打人致死是……的一种常见情节。
I think they're totally true. There's enough missionary. Some of these missionaries are very pious and slightly dull people. They're not making stuff up. The climax of this is he locks them all in a sort of black hole of Calcutta-style cellar. And he comes in, they're running the cellar, like hunched over in their chains. He comes in with a bottle of Arak, kind of racky type thing, and sits down and just they're drinking and talking to them.
我认为它们完全是真的。有足够的传教士。其中一些传教士非常虔诚，有点沉闷。他们不是在编造东西。这件事的高潮是他把他们都锁在一个类似加尔各答黑洞式的地窖里。他进来了，他们在地窖里，戴着镣铐蜷缩着。他拿着一瓶阿拉克酒，那种类似烧酒的东西，坐下来，他们就在喝酒聊天。
And they find that very stressful. Can I ask, what language are they talking in? He speaks Amharic. And do they by now speak it? I guess they do. They must speak some. Maybe there's interpreters there that we don't know about. But I think they must understand.
他们觉得这非常令人紧张。我可以问一下，他们用什么语言交谈吗？他说阿姆哈拉语。他们现在会说这种语言吗？我想他们会。他们肯定会说一些。也许那里有我们不知道的翻译。但我认为他们一定能听懂。
Maybe they can only pick up one in every four words, but I think they get the gist. Alexander, Solomon. He's drinking and chatting. And then at the very end, he's finished the bottle and he says to them very quietly and slightly sadly, My father was mad. And though people often say that I am mad, I never would believe it. But now I know it's true. and then Rassam says to him,
也许他们只能听懂四分之一的单词，但我认为他们抓住了要点。亚历山大，所罗门。他在喝酒聊天。最后，他喝完了酒，非常安静且略带悲伤地对他们说，我的父亲疯了。虽然人们常说我疯了，但我从不相信。但现在我知道这是真的。然后拉萨姆对他说，
don't say such a thing. And Teodros gets up and he goes to the doorway and he looks back and he says in a horse whisper, I am mad. Goodbye. And that off he goes. I think that's a bit disconcerting, frankly. So that's the last they see of him for almost two years.
别说这种话。特沃德罗斯站起来走到门口，回头用嘶哑的耳语说，我疯了。再见。然后他就走了。坦率地说，我觉得这有点令人不安。所以这是他们近两年来最后一次见到他。
Two years? Yeah. They're left in that cellar for two years. No, no. They brought out again. In fact, what happens to them is they're taken back up to Magdala to the mountain citadel, 10,000 feet above sea level, and they're chained up and they're put in their huts.
两年？是的。他们被关在地窖里两年。不，不。他们又被带出来了。事实上，发生的事情是他们被带回马格达拉的山顶堡垒，海拔10000英尺，被锁起来关在小屋里。
Teodros goes off to fight some rebels. He's now proceeding with extreme cruelty, taking thousands of prisoners, massacring villages, stealing people's sacred books, all this. So this is the picture that greets this guy flat when he returns to the coast. And the letters that he's got from the missionaries are all very bleak.
特沃德罗斯去打叛军了。他现在以极端的残忍行事，抓捕了数千名囚犯，屠杀村庄，偷走人们的神圣书籍，所有这些。这就是弗拉德回到海岸时迎接他的景象。他从传教士那里得到的信件都非常凄凉。
So the Swiss missionary Theophanus Valdemeyer says, If you brought all this stuff, you might as well throw it in the sea, because Teodros would rather cut all the Europeans into a thousand pieces, then hand them over. And Flad's wife, Pauline, has written him a very depressing letter. I entreat you, don't trust, don't trust, don't trust. If the workmen come, not a single soul will be able to leave the country. Flad, however, is determined to come anyway. So he rides through this sort of war-ravaged landscape, and he finds Teodros in his camp,
所以瑞士传教士西奥法努斯·瓦尔德迈尔说，如果你带来了所有这些东西，你还不如把它们扔进海里，因为特沃德罗斯宁愿把所有欧洲人切成碎片，也不会把他们交出来。弗拉德的妻子宝琳写了一封非常令人沮丧的信给他。我恳求你，不要相信，不要相信，不要相信。如果工人们来了，没有一个人能离开这个国家。然而，弗拉德还是决定要来。于是他骑马穿过这片饱受战争蹂躏的土地，在营地里找到了特沃德罗斯，
and rather disconcertingly, Teodros is surrounded by the rotting bodies of starved horses. It's actually a bit like George Washington's camp at Valley Forge. Not clearing them up. Yeah. And Flad presents Teodros with the telescope. A little taster of the gifts he will have
令人不安的是，特沃德罗斯周围是饿死的马的腐烂尸体。这实际上有点像乔治·华盛顿在福吉谷的营地。没有清理它们。是的。弗拉德向特沃德罗斯展示了望远镜。这是他将要得到的礼物的一点点预尝
when he releases the hostages. Geotros throws the telescope aside. And he says, The man who sends with his telescope only wants to annoy me. Chodros says, What's your queen got to say? And Flad says, well, basically, if you don't release the hostages, you have no right to expect any further friendship. Teodros is shocked by this.
当他释放人质时。特沃德罗斯把望远镜扔到一边。他说，送望远镜的人只是想惹我生气。特沃德罗斯说，你的女王有什么要说的？弗拉德说，嗯，基本上，如果你不释放人质，你就没有权利期待任何进一步的友谊。特沃德罗斯对此感到震惊。
He's totally silent. And then he says quietly, very well. I ask from them a sign of friendship, but it is refused to me. So be it. Flad has led away to join the hostages. So this is his reunion. I mean, he basically voluntarily goes back into captivity to see his wife. children. And that, it seems as that. Chodros is not going to let them go. The British are not
他完全沉默了。然后他平静地说，好吧。我向他们寻求友谊的标志，但被拒绝了。就这样吧。弗拉德被带走去加入人质行列。这就是他的重逢。我的意思是，他基本上是自愿回到囚禁中去见他的妻子和孩子。事情似乎就是这样。特沃德罗斯不会放他们走。英国人不会
going to give him all his equipment, a total stalemate. And the stalemate remains like that for six months. Chodras is off fighting rebels. The hostages are all huddled together at Magdala, and they're hearing ever more sort of blood-curdling rumours about his growing madness and cruelty. They are convinced that eventually he will come back to Magdal and he will just say kill the lot of them. In March 1867, Dr. Blanc writes a note that is smuggled to the coast and then to the foreign office. And he says, I'm going to tell you the whole story to Audros in his rise, his crimes, our plight, his madness. And Blanc says, the time for talking to this guy is over, and I quote, only one thing remains force. But of course, Dr. Blanc doesn't know whether his note is even
给他所有的设备，完全陷入僵局。僵局就这样持续了六个月。特沃德罗斯去打叛军了。人质们都挤在马格达拉，他们听到了越来越多关于他日益增长的疯狂和残忍的令人毛骨悚然的传闻。他们确信他最终会回到马格达拉，然后说杀了他们所有人。1867年3月，布兰克医生写了一张便条，被偷运到海岸，然后送到外交部。他说，我要告诉你关于特沃德罗斯的整个故事，他的崛起，他的罪行，我们的困境，他的疯狂。布兰克说，和这个家伙谈话的时间结束了，我引用，只剩下一件事，武力。但当然，布兰克医生不知道他的便条是否
going to get there or whether anybody is listening or anything like this. And then one day in the early summer of 1867, a messenger stumbles into Teodros' camp and he has a letter come from the Red Sea coast. And the letter is an ultimatum from London. The British government have lost patience. They're giving him three months to release the hostages. And after that, they will cut off all talks and the implication is that they will begin military action. Is Teodroscano except? Spoiler.
能送到，或者是否有人在听，或者类似的事情。然后，1867年初夏的一天，一名信使跌跌撞撞地走进特沃德罗斯的营地，他带来了一封来自红海海岸的信。这封信是伦敦发出的最后通牒。英国政府已经失去了耐心。他们给他三个月的时间释放人质。在那之后，他们将切断所有谈判，暗示他们将开始军事行动。特沃德罗斯会接受吗？剧透。
He will not. And so it is that on the 19th of August, 1867, Lord Darby's cabinet meet in London to decide their next move and there's never any doubt really about what that will be. Diplomacy has failed. It is time for war.
他不会。因此，1867年8月19日，达比勋爵的内阁在伦敦开会决定他们的下一步行动，对于那将是什么，从来没有任何疑问。外交失败了。是时候开战了。
It's war. What a cliffhanger, unbelievable drama and members. of the Restis City Club can find out what happens next, the story of Sir Robert Napier's Abyssinian Expedition expedition and the great battle for Magdalas right now. And we have a special incentive, Dominic, this week, because club members will be getting a special bonus on some of the great characters of this story, the hostages, the adventurers, and particularly the mad story of what happened to Teodris's son, who improbably ended up as a schoolboy in one of
是战争。多么悬念，令人难以置信的戏剧性，历史俱乐部的成员们现在就可以找出接下来发生了什么，罗伯特·纳皮尔爵士的阿比西尼亚远征的故事以及马格达拉的大战。多米尼克，我们本周有一个特别的激励，因为俱乐部成员将获得关于这个故事中一些伟大人物的特别奖励，人质、冒险家，特别是关于特沃德罗斯儿子的疯狂故事，他不可思议地成为了其中一所学校的学生
England's great public schools. And not just any school. He went to Flashman's old school. Rugby. Amazing. So to hear all that, and to hear episode two, if you're not already member of the Restis History Club, you can go to the rest is history.com. But for now, thank you, Dominic. Goodbye. Bye-bye. 350 passengers. The great game, strategic struggle between Britain and Russia. We assess our Prime Minister. With high confidence, it was Russian.
英国伟大的公立学校。不仅仅是任何学校。他去了弗莱什曼的老学校。拉格比公学。太棒了。所以要听到所有这些，并听到第二集，如果你还不是历史俱乐部的成员，你可以去therestishistory.com。但现在，谢谢你，多米尼克。再见。再见。350名乘客。大博弈，英国和俄罗斯之间的战略斗争。我们评估我们的首相。高度自信，是俄罗斯人。
Holding the Russians accountable is World War III. They took down a British passenger jet containing 350 people. Man in the Kremlin is playing, Alex. Got to ask yourself, do you want to play or not? You're the Prime Minister. You've done. Nothing! We would need to understand the policy context.
追究俄罗斯人的责任就是第三次世界大战。他们击落了一架载有350人的英国客机。克里姆林宫的那个人在玩弄，亚历克斯。你得问问自己，你想玩还是不想玩？你是首相。你什么都没做！我们需要了解政策背景。
All the relevant context will be structured as a framework today, and disseminated into an operation order, or Fraggo. A Fraggo that says to kill the president of Russia. Yes. New from Gullhanger. Who is going to be able to pull this off? You're my soldier, are you? Sergeant Tom McDuffeuf.
今天所有相关的背景都将构建为一个框架，并分发到作战命令或Fraggo中。一个说要杀死俄罗斯总统的Fraggo。是的。来自Gullhanger的新消息。谁能做到这一点？你是我的士兵，对吧？汤姆·麦克达夫中士。
An audio drama journey like... No other. Men like Duffy, they are our most valuable weapons. Devised as a technically rigorous, geopolitical action thriller. We have two types of friendly key. Where Britain plays its strongest hand. He's the best. Against its strongest foe. Bear Hunt.
一段音频戏剧之旅……无与伦比。像达菲这样的人，是我们最宝贵的武器。被设计为一部技术严谨的地缘政治动作惊悚片。我们有两种类型的友好关键。英国发挥其最强手牌的地方。他是最好的。对抗其最强大的敌人。猎熊。
Available now, wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
现在可以在你获取播客的任何地方收听。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。